bien bonjour à
re-bonjour à toutes et à tous puisque
nous avons déjà eu ce matin l'audition
de Monsieur Fontana
dirige Framatome et nous nous retrouvons
cet après-midi pour l'audition de
Monsieur Gadonneix président d'honneur
de DF
pour la dernière réunion de la semaine
de notre commission d'enquête
chargée d'établir les raisons de la
perte de souveraineté d'indépendance
énergétique de la France nous avons donc
le privilège de recevoir Monsieur Pierre
gannenex en sa qualité de président
d'honneur d'EDF
nous vous remercions d'abord d'avoir
accepté si rapidement notre invitation
et il me revient de préciser que vous
avez été président en 2df après la
transformation de cette entreprise en
société anonyme de 2004 à 2009
il est utile de rappeler également que
pendant 17 ans vous avez exercé des
responsabilités importantes au sein de
Gaz de France GDF de 1987 à 2004 donc
précédemment à vos fonctions au sein de
EDF comme directeur général puis comme
président
votre expérience dans la conduite de
l'ouverture des marchés énergétiques est
sans doute inégalée des rapports
nouveaux ont dû en effet se nouer avec
les actionnaires et le premier d'entre
eux l'État
la période au cours de laquelle la
gestion d'EDF vous a été confiée a été
riche très riche en évolution tout
d'abord la coexistence au sein de
l'entreprise de source diverses
d'électricité le nucléaire prépondérant
mais aussi les centrales hydrauliques
les centrales thermiques et ce que l'on
appelait alors les énergies nouvelles
chaque branche représentant des
investissements et des actifs importants
ensuite à côté de ce capital un
personnel compétent et attaché à
l'entreprise est indispensable au bon à
son bon fonctionnement une
réorganisation voulait voulu par les
instances européennes a par ailleurs
conduit à séparer les activités de
transport et de distribution tout en
tentant de maintenir une cohérence et
les synergies nécessaires au sein du
système électrique français
la filiation de ces différentes
entreprises qui s'occupent de chacun de
ces espaces de l'ensemble du champ
énergétique ayant été la méthode retenue
le principe d'un développement des
interconnexions fut alors affirmé
la période a en outre précédait
l'accident de Fukushima elle s'annonçait
propice au développement du nucléaire
tente en France que dans le monde et EDF
a saisi plusieurs opportunités pour
réaliser des investissements à
l'étranger
les réacteurs français avaient alors une
moyenne d'âge de 17 ans et l'ont songé
alors à atteindre une durée de vie de 40
années pour ce parc le chantier de
Flamanville a été ouvert au cours de
votre mandat et dès le départ le rôle
d'architecte ensemblier d'EDF a été
revendiqué tandis que Areva NP cherchait
à se développer et que la SN se montrait
particulièrement vigilante
l'enfouissement des lignes électriques
pour préserver les cités paysages et
diminuer leur exposition aux intempéries
faisaient alors débat EDF devait
investir et une stratégie industrielle
semble être envoi de constitution
parallèlement les travaux de la
commission conduite par Marcel Roulet
ont mis en évidence les besoins de
financement nécessaires à cette ambition
ouvrant un débat sur la revalorisation
des tarifs
ces quelques jalons révèlent l'ampleur
des tâches qui vous ont été confiées
votre témoignage permettra à notre
commission d'enquête de mieux
appréhender les défis auxquels le
système énergétique français a dû
répondre sous votre autorité et les
difficultés rencontrées monsieur
gadennec je vais m'arrêter là de mon
propos de productif et vous laissez la
parole pour votre propos introductif
mais avant cela il me revient de vous
demander en vertu de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires de bien
vouloir prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité et rien que la vérité je
vous prie en conséquence de bien vouloir
lever la main droite et de dire je le
jure
je vous remercie et je vous invite donc
à allumer votre micro pour votre propos
il suffit d'appuyer sur le bouton
là
tout d'abord je voulais vous féliciter
parce que le la présentation fait appel
à des
pas mal de
faits qui sont en effet important et je
justement à la commission roulette c'est
pas très connu ça a été oublié et c'est
en effet un aspect important bon tout
d'abord je vais vous dire que je suis
pas étonné d'être là et je trouve ça
tout à fait légitime comme interroge
comme vous avez vous l'avez rappelé j'ai
beaucoup vécu
au sein d'EDF et de Gaz de France
puisqu'à l'époque c'est un temps qu'on a
oublié mais
pendant toute la période où j'étais à
Gaz de France les deux entreprises
étaient très proches elles avaient elles
étaient nationalisées toutes les deux à
100% public et elles avaient en commun
l'activité de distribution c'est à dire
les réseaux et la commercialisation
auprès des particuliers enfin la
distribution et toute la gestion du
personnel
et donc
j'ai été
familier de ces entreprises et je garde
très profond attachement à leur
évolution
et c'est donc avec beaucoup de tristesse
que je constate la dégradation du modèle
français et que j'ai connu et ce modèle
s'est dégradé depuis 10 ans en effet
je voudrais vous rappeler quand j'étais
quand on m'a demandé de prendre la
présidence de Gaz de France
c'était en 2004
j'avais déjà été pendant vous l'avez
rappelé 17 ans à Gaz de France je
souligne à cette occasion
combien la cette époque il y avait une
certaine stabilité et pérennité dans le
management de l'entreprise et quand j'ai
eu l'honneur de quitter Gaz de France
Gaz de France était dans une santé tout
à fait satisfaisante et
j'étais pas du tout candidat pour
prendre les f j’étais très heureux à Gaz
de France et je pense il poursuivre mon
activité jusqu'à la retraite mais j'ai
dû être j'ai été appelé parce que j'y
reviendrai EDF connaissait une situation
un petit peu difficile sur un certain
nombre de plans mais également ce que je
voudrais rappeler qu'en 2004
le on arrivait à la fin du grand
programme d'investissement de
développement du nucléaire de EDF c'est
je vous ai d'ailleurs remis sous les
yeux là une chronologie que j'utilisais
souvent
pendant que j'étais à la tête de DF pour
échanger avec les parties prenantes que
ça soit les pouvoirs publics les
actionnaires le personnel parce que ça
montre bien
ce qui a carnet l'évolution de EDF donc
on arrivait en 2002
en 2004 on était à la fin du programme
d'investissement qui avait été lancé de
manière assez extraordinaire qui a fait
le
référence dans le monde entier le monde
entier a été admiratif de ce qui avait
fait la France c'était le plan besper
qui avait été annoncé le 6 mars 74 et
juste après c'était du temps du
président Pompidou juste après son décès
c'est le président Giscard qui a si
j'ose dire hérité de ce discours qu'il
était qu'à discours et c'est pendant son
mandature que ce programme a été
effectivement lancé et sa réalisation
est une réussite absolument reconnue
mondialement 58 réacteurs construits en
25 ans avec une capacité de 62 gigawatts
et qui faisait qu'à la fin de ce cycle
d'investissement
il y avait
un parc très largement accidentaire et
les délais de construction des du parc
ont été d'environ 7 ans c'est lors de
grandeur 5 à 7 ans
ce parc on l'a oublié maintenant mais je
le rappelle parce que c'est important
pour la suite
a été entièrement
construit en utilisant une technologie
américaine qui était Westinghouse
c'était oublié aujourd'hui
ça a été un grand débat il y a une
grande bataille mais à la fin EDF a fait
le choix de prendre une stratégie une
technologie existante et pour laquelle
il y avait déjà des dizaines de
réacteurs qui fonctionnaient aux
États-Unis et la grande réussite qui est
une réussite de politiques industrielle
la France a réussi pendant cette période
à francisé ce qui était une licence
américaine
et la franchisé en plusieurs temps
d'abord la racheté à la licence et je
pense que je vais vous apprendre quelque
chose que vous avez tous envie de noter
cette licence a été portée par une
structure et à l'époque on a imaginé un
nom pour cette structure et on a dit
framatoome Framatome tout le monde l'a
oublié aujourd'hui ça voulait dire
France Amérique à Tom donc franc bateau
mais à l'origine était le détenteur de
la licence et après grâce à une
intelligence des pouvoirs publics
d'abinome que je respecte beaucoup qui
étaient monsieur André Giraud qui a été
pas trop du CEA plus ministre et Marcel
Boiteux avec la complicité des pouvoirs
publics ils ont réussi à franchiser
complètement la licence et aujourd'hui
et depuis de cette époque là la
technologie est complètement maîtrisée
par la France il n'y a plus aucun lien
avec
Westinghouse mais c'est important pour
la suite moi ça m'avait beaucoup guidé
les centrales que nous construisons
rigoureusement les mêmes que celle de
westingen aux États-Unis il y a pas un
boulon de différence c'est comme quand
vous prenez un Boeing c'est le même
qu'il soit fabriqué il y a 20 ans il y a
10 ans
donc formidable réussite mais faut pas
mais oui on a été un rythme de
construction de 5 centrales par an je
sais pas si vous imaginez cinq parents
bon et ça c'était dans la perspective ou
le contexte ou la croissance de la
demande à l'époque était de 7% par an la
demande d'électricité ce qui veut dire
un doublement tous les 10 ans bon cette
demande a commencé à affaiblir la
croissance affaiblir pour arriver à
s'annuler d'ailleurs aujourd'hui mais
déjà à l'époque ça commençait à se
ralentir donc il y avait trop de
capacités donc on a arrêté complètement
de construire complètement et il y a eu
pratiquement 10 ans d'arrêt sans aucune
construction
et
il y avait donc une excellente et quand
je suis arrivé en 2004 il y avait
environ 20% d'excellents de capacités
et
j'ai eu l'honneur de d'être nommé à ce
moment-là
et donc j'étais nommé le 15 septembre
2004 jusqu'à 22 novembre
alors quel était le constat quand j'ai
fait en 2004 c'est je suis un peu les
questions que vous m'avez posé en effet
alors le premier constat c'est la
réussite fabuleuse du programme
nucléaire il y a aucun doute là-dessus
qui n'était
reconnu mondialement j'y reviendrai nous
étions le leader à contesté du nucléaire
dans le monde incontesté
constat et bien malgré cela il y avait
une dégradation importante de la
trésorerie et vous l'avez fait allusion
en effet mon arrivée il y avait une
commission la commission roulait qui
avait c'était inquiété avait fait une
enquête sur les origines de ces
difficultés qui étaient des difficultés
très horrible à l'entreprise était
rentable il y avait des pertes de
trésorerie alors d'où venait ces pertes
de trésorerie
essentiellement il y a eu des
investissements malheureux à l'étranger
tous les investissements à l'étranger ne
sont pas malheureux mais il y en a eu
quelques-uns malheureux en Argentine au
Brésil
qui était des réseaux de distribution et
dans ces deux pays les tarifs avaient
été bloqués et donc les entreprises
étaient complètement déficitaires
et puis il y avait une tentative de
reprise d'Edison qui avait été heurté à
une opposition politique du gouvernement
italien et donc EDF se trouve dans la
situation de n'avoir que je crois 3% des
droits de vote et potentiellement devoir
à payer
le compte plus de 50% des actions si
l'actionnaire le coactionnaire de DF qui
est à l'époque Fiat exercée son foot
le jour de mon arrivée ou la semaine
d'après il a exercé son pote donc nous
avions une menace d'avoir à dépenser
près des milliards de trésorerie
uniquement pour honorer ce put
en même temps ou juste avant
l'entreprise avait baissé ses tarifs
d'électricité c'est ce que vous voyez
sur la courbe d'environ 20% au cours des
cinq prochaines années précédentes c'est
la courbe rouge
alors vous voyez la courbe rouge à
baisse des tarifs il y a toute une
partie au début des années 80 aux années
87 là qui qui correspond à la fin du
programme d'investissement donc c'est
logique que
et qui est un retour
vers des tarifs qui reflètent les
besoins de l'entreprise mais après il y
a eu des baisses de tarifs qui
ont été
mises en œuvre en
faisant le choix ou le pari qu'on allait
arrêter d'investir alors vous voyez les
investissements notamment les
investissements de production on
pratiquement disparu alors c'était la
fin du programme nucléaire mais quand je
suis arrivé vous voyez il y avait moins
de 1 milliard près de 500 millions
seulement d'investissements
et
là c'est mon expérience j'avais été
pendant 17 ans à Gaz de France la
première chose que j'ai fait ça a été de
visiter les installations un peu de
différents types
hydraulique thermique nucléaire et j'ai
pris conscience qu'il y avait un retard
et un besoin gigantesque
d'investissement et ça a été une de mes
premières priorités alors vous m'avez
posé la question et j'ai envie d'y
répondre avec clarté qu'elles étaient
mes priorités pendant que j'ai conduit
ces
la gestion de l'entreprise pendant un
peu plus de 5 ans
bien je on y réfléchissant j'en ai
défini quatre
la première qui a été de loin
celle que qui m'a préoccupé le plus vite
c'était leur lance dans l'investissement
j'ai pris ce j'ai fait ce constat dès
mon arrivée quelques semaines après mon
arrivée j'ai constaté que l'entreprise
avait complètement arrêté d'investir je
peux vous dire le premier choc ça a été
quand j'étais visité une installation
hydraulique j'avais été visité ce qui
est formidable d'ailleurs le c'est tout
le système de la Durance parce que vous
connaissez il y a un système
extraordinaire le
système hydraulique qui date dans la
prière là la Durance est canalisée
depuis le lac de Serre-Ponçon
et va jusqu’à la mer à l'étang de Berre
et là il y a 17 barrages et c'est 17
barrages communiquent par des canaux et
si vous appuyez sur un bouton c'est une
prouesse de la France vous appuyez sur
un bouton les 17 barrages se mettent
ensemble en marche en même temps il faut
les mettre tous en même temps parce que
sinon ça déborde donc faut appuyer sur
les 17 et ça fait 3000 mégawatts c'est à
dire en quelques secondes vous pouvez
avoir 3000 mégawatts mon style réussite
formidable alors j'ai vu ça c'était très
beau puis après j'ai été voir les usines
à l'intérieur parce qu'il y a des usines
et ayant été un peu dans les tuyaux j'ai
trouvé que les tuyaux étaient pas en
très bon état et j'avais raison donc on
a relancé l'investissement massivement
je sais pas si vous voulez l'heure de
grandeur entre début de mon arrivée et
quand je suis parti les investissements
de production étaient multipliés par 10
et le réseau était moins moins
mauvais état honnêtement
j'ai plutôt augmenté mais le réseau
avait été
convenablement tenue on a augmenté mais
il n'y a pas de rupture majeur
deuxième
et puis en même temps
j'ai lancé enfin en même temps que
l'investissement de maintenance j'ai
lancé des turbines à combustion on a
fabriqué des produits la combustion
parce que
c'était à l'époque nous étions monopole
et donc on se sentait responsable de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement et les
turbines à combustion coûtent cher
en coût variable mais pas très peu en
cours en confix donc c'est ce qui permet
de faire face au pointes donc on avait
le on avait estimé qu'il y avait un
besoin de capacité de pointe les
turbines à combustion fonctionne que
quelques heures par an
contrairement à une centrale nucléaire
qui fonctionne tout le temps
deuxième priorité c'est celle qui que
vous avez pour ça que j'ai apprécié le
résumé que vous avez fait parce que je
pense que vous avez en effet
identifié les points qui ont été pour
moi marquants ça a été la relance de la
compétence nucléaire ça a été un point
majeur
j'en parlerai tout à l'heure le contexte
s'y prêtait il y a pas de mais on avait
arrêté d'investir on avait arrêté
d'investir parce qu'on n'avait pas de
besoin de capacité et donc j'étais
arrivé à la valise ça faisait 15 ans
pratiquement qu'on n'est pas lancé de
centrale 15 ans et j'étais à l'analyse
qui disait on va pas en avoir besoin
avant 20 ans de nouvelles centrales
c'était l'ordre de grandeur si on attend
on aura perdu la compétence 30 ans sans
fabriquer de centrales le tissu
industriel se délite et les compétences
y compris les salariés de la maison ou
de toute la filière
ne seront pas remplacés donc il fallait
absolument relancer les compétences et
le raisonnement que j'ai fait ça a été
au bout de 6 mois à peu près après avoir
beaucoup discuté avec les uns les autres
en interne en externe ça a été le
raisonnement suivant
1 nous centrales avaient une durée de
vie affichée de 40 ans point que vous
avez souligné et j'ai noté que c'était
un point important en effet
aux États-Unis les mêmes centrales sont
autorisés pour 60 ans et 70 ans les
mêmes même boulon même sécurité même
tout donc je suis arrivé et à l'époque
j'avais des relations étroites mais de
confiance avec l'Autorité de sûreté et
nous étions tombés d'accord que la
possibilité d'étendre la durée de vie
des centrales de 40 ans à 60 ans était
évidemment de loin
l'investissement le plus rentable pour
la France parce qu'au lieu de construire
des centrales nouvelles on prolonge de
20 ans les centrales existantes ce qu'on
fait les Américains ce qu'on fait Westie
ce qu'on fait les centrales de washingt
donc ça a été ma première priorité mais
ça ça veut dire
qu'on retarde d'autant le jour où on va
renouveler des nouvelles centrales donc
à la limite on va tout le tissu
industriel il y aura une partie qui sera
mobilisée sur le l'extension de la durée
de vie puisque c'est quand même des
travaux importants qui ont été baptisés
après moi d'ailleurs grand carénage mais
c'est quand même pas aussi lourd que de
faire des nouvelles centrales donc si on
veut vraiment mobiliser une filière et
dans 20 ans avoir une capacité il faut
constituer de quoi justifier une filière
industrielle et donc j'ai réussi à
convaincre les pouvoirs publics et je
dois dire sur ce point que j'ai eu un
soutien total à 100%, suite à l'époque
président Sarkozy mais toute l'équipe
que malgré le fait qu'il y ait des
surcapacités il me paraissait nécessaire
de fabriquer une centrale en France une
tous les deux ans j'ai dit une
inflammment en ville le plus vite
possible et puis une autre a pas envie
et j'ai eu le feu vert sur les deux et
en même temps ce qui c'est qui est
important et exporter notre compétence
pour développer du nucléaire ailleurs
qu'en France parce que le nucléaire
était en train de reprendre du poil de
la bête dans l'opinion internationale il
y a eu un arrêt il y avait Tchernobyl
et cher par terre et donc il y avait des
pays qui s'intéressaient au nucléaire et
donc et comme nous étions le leader
incontesté j'ai ciblé quatre pays
l'Angleterre la Grande-Bretagne j'y
reviendrai parce que c'est celui
aujourd'hui qui va sauver la filière
nucléaire
la Grande-Bretagne mais j'avais pensé
aussi à la Chine où nous avons développé
Tashan
aux États-Unis où on avait un
partenariat
aux États-Unis avec
la société
et en Italie un petit peu mais
enfin ça a avancé en Italie puisque
les Italiens le partenaire a pris une
participation dans le dans le dans le
projet de Penly il s'est retiré après
mais
c'était NL et l'américain dont je
cherchais le nom c'était constellations
et mon idée était à l'époque de choisir
parce que le nucléaire c'est toujours un
sujet très politique très sensible et
donc je disais il faut arriver avec un
partenaire local reconnu
c'est ce que j'ai fait en Chine
évidemment avec CGNPC
en Angleterre j'y reviendrai
c'était British énergie qui était le
leader et mon idée était de faire un
partenariat avec British énergies on a
fini par prendre 100% du capital
bon en elle était appartenait le
n'était pas n'avait pas encore réussi à
convaincre les pouvoirs publics de
réinvestir mais il s'intéressait à
développer des compétences donc je les
avais associés au chantier de
Flamanville et ils avaient pris une
participation
pour développer des compétences
troisième priorité donc reconstituer le
nucléaire reconstituer la compétence de
nucléaire
troisième priorité ça a été développé un
pôle renouvelable à l'époque le
renouvelable commençait à apparaître
comme crédible contester mes crédits et
j'étais arrivé à cette époque à la
conclusion que ça allait devenir un
complément du nucléaire donc il était
absolument nécessaire pour l'entreprise
d'avoir ce volet mais j'étais aussi
arrivé à la conclusion que les
compétences pour réussir à développer le
renouvelable n'était pas les compétences
qu'on avait en interne l'interne la
force d'EDF à l'époque pour moi c'était
l'ingénierie hydraulique thermique
nucléaire on savait faire des barrages
on savait faire des usines le
renouvelable j'évite compris que les
qualités qu'il fallait pour réussir
n'était pas les mêmes et donc je me suis
tourné vers une société qui s'appelait
six énergie à l'époque qui a été dirigée
par un brillant entrepreneur monsieur
moratoglou et avec son bras droit David
Corchia qui avait réussi plusieurs fois
parce qu'ils avaient j'avais développé
revendu développé revendu ils ont fait
ça au moins trois fois et on a développé
un partenariat et quand j'ai quitté EDF
nous étions à 50 EDF avec 50 % la
société était cotée et on était en
congestion avec le le dirigeant avec
l'idée à terme de prendre le contrôle ce
qui est arrivé après moi mais avec une
équipe dédiée
avec les compétences les compétences
dans le domaine j'ai vite compris c'est
arrivé à obtenir les subventions
importantes parce que c'est une énergie
très subventionnée et deuxièmement
obtenir les autorisations des pour les
implantations il y a ces difficultés
c'est une très grande difficulté pour
s'implanter dans le renouvelable que ce
soit l'éolien surtout l'éolien mais le
solaire aussi donc il faut arriver tout
un réseau et des des
compétences pour convaincre les
populations et les élus d'accueillir ces
infrastructures
troisième priorité c'est dégager les
moyens de financement parce que comme
vous voyez sur le diagramme que je monte
je prévoyais une forte augmentation des
investissements
quand je dis investissement de
production c'était pour partir de
matière en bon état les installations
existantes renouveler le matériel et
puis développer certaines capacités
nouvelles et donc
cette augmentation des investissements
et
si vous voulez tout à l'heure je
pourrais vous le montrer on avait
commencé à réfléchir le renouvellement
du nucléaire qui sera en deux étapes je
viens de le dire 1 la prolongation de la
durée de vie des centrales existantes
mais c'est quand même un coût important
à l'époque on pensait que ça serait de
l'ordre de 500 millions par centrale
maintenant c'est plutôt un milliard
je reviendrai pourquoi les les cours ont
dérapés mais c'est incontestable bon
donc ça fait des montants investiments
importants et puis après fabriquer des
nouvelles centrales donc pour tout ça il
fallait dégager des moyens de
financement alors qu'est-ce comment j'ai
essayé d'augmenter de trouver les moyens
de financement à court terme mais ça a
été l'augmentation de capital qui a été
réalisé en novembre 2005 qui rapportait
7,5 milliards à l'entreprise
augmentation de capital entièrement
c'est pas à cette époque là c'est pas
l'état qu'avant du sépare c'est de
l'argent qui est venu financer le
développement d'EDF 7 milliards et demi
deuxièmement
prévoir des rattrapages des tarifs parce
que les tarifs avaient été fondés sur le
fait que l'entreprise n'avait plus loin
d'investir et donc il fallait absolument
corriger ça on y reviendra et enfin
développer la productivité et la
pression pour développer la productivité
venez aussi vous avez fait allusion tout
à l'heure à la notion d'ouverture et
donc on voyait bien qu'on allait se
trouver de plus en plus confronté à une
compétition à une confrontation et donc
il était important de faire en sorte que
notre activité soit la plus efficace
possible alors comment était EDF quand
je suis parti en novembre 2019
ben écoutez
la capacité de production a été stable
puisqu'il n'y a pas eu de développement
de mon temps mais le parc était en bon
état et le taux disponibilité
était satisfaisant il était de l'ordre
de
80%, je dois dire qu'on a une alerte de
mon temps j'avais au cours de mon mandat
constaté que le taux disponibilité avait
tendance à baisser ce qui justifiait
complètement les efforts qu'on avait
fait sur les investissements de pour
entretenir les centrales
le
le la prolongation des centrales
d'une durée de 20 ans apparaissait comme
tout à fait possible l'Autorité de
sûreté c'était monsieur Lacoste à
l'époque qui était le président
l'Autorité de sûreté était tout à fait
intéressé à cette perspective qui
permettait en maintenant la sûreté de de
diminuer les coûts parce que c'est du
milieu les coûts quand on peut prolonger
une centrale de 20 ans ça diminue les
coûts et enfin la réussite de en
Grande-Bretagne quand je suis parti on
avait réussi à s'implanter en Bretagne
je voudrais vous dire une anecdote parce
qu'elle est importante sur la relation
entre le politique et l'entreprise
quand je suis allé en Grande Bretagne
mon idée c'était de prendre une
participation manorite minoritaire dans
une société qui s'appelait British
énergie comme EDF s'appelle Électricité
de France
et donc évidemment quand on fait une
opération comme ça j'ai été voir les
gouvernement donc j'ai rencontré
Monsieur Tony Blair à l'époque était
premier ministre et je lui ai dit mon
intention est de faire un partenariat
avec British énergie et
mon intention est pour le faire c'était
de développer le nucléaire en
Grande-Bretagne
les autorités britanniques étaient très
intéressés par le développement du
nucléaire en Bretagne et il m'a dit
écoutez nous c'est incroyable le Premier
ministre de Grande-Bretagne m'a dit nous
on préfère que vous preniez le contrôle
et quand j'ai on a pris le contrôle j'ai
été voir le Premier ministre je lui ai
demandé est-ce que ça vous gêne qu'elle
s'appelait British énergie on va
l'appeler EDF énergie il a dit pas du
tout parce que on a confiance dans l'EDF
EDF pour nous c'est la garantie que le
nucléaire sera un succès
et deuxième chose que je veux vous dire
vous raconter sur le la notion de
politique et la manière dont la
Grande-Bretagne conçoit la politique
énergétique lorsque j'ai vu Toni Blair
il m'a dit je suis Premier ministre le
nucléaire c'est un
projet à temps long je vous invite à
voir mon successeur qui est Monsieur
Gandon Brown ils se sont passés le
relais entre dans le même parti j'ai été
voir Monsieur Gordon Braun qui m'a
confirmé le soutien total du
gouvernement britannique sur le projet
de d'EDF de développer nucléaire en
Bretagne et il m'a dit
je serais vous j'irai voir l'opposition
donc j'ai pris rendez-vous avec Monsieur
Cameron qui était en opposition
monsieur Cameron m'a fait attendre 6
mois
et donc j'avais toujours pas investi
parce que je voulais être sûr de mon
coup il m'a fait attendre 6 mois au bout
de 6 mois il m'a reçu il m'a dit écoutez
je vous ai fait attendre 6 mois parce
que il y a 6 mois je ne sais pas ce que
je vous aurais dit aujourd'hui je peux
vous le confirmer nous serons élus parce
que les sondages étaient favorables et
nous soutiendrons le nucléaire
je peux vous pouvez observer qu'après
mon départ il y a eu des alternances en
Grande-Bretagne le soutien politique du
gouvernement à EDF en Grande-Bretagne a
été absolument sans faille j'y
reviendrai extraordinaire et donc avec
ça quand je suis parti j'avais tout à
fait confiance qu'on aurait une de quoi
alimenter une filière nucléaire avec la
construction de ninkle point puisqu'il y
a deux centrales à une épon qui sont en
construction qui ont été lancés du temps
où j'étais là et il y a de mon temps il
y avait deux en projets sasuelles qui
ont été confirmés la semaine dernière je
sais pas si vous l'avez vu et qui donc
ont de quoi alimenter au moins la partie
amont de la compétence nucléaire
enfin
troisième point quand j'ai quitté
l'entreprise
c'était la situation financière alors là
autant j'ai été soutenu à 100% sur tous
les sujets que je viens d'évoquer y
compris l'idée d'aller construire en
France des centrales et d'aller en
Grande-Bretagne
investir pour pouvoir développer du
nucléaire en Grande-Bretagne autant j'ai
pas été suivi sur le la partie tarifaire
tous les diagrammes que je vous montre
là où je montre le l'évolution des
investissements et puis vous pouvez voir
sur les diagrammes d'après qui donne un
peu plus de détails sur le moteur des
investissements
et le troisième vous voyez de le
troisième diagramme montre que
la France les activités en France
n'étaient plus auto-financés
c'est-à-dire que les ressources de cache
de cash flow ne permettait pas de
financer le les investissements et donc
c'est un modèle qui ne peut plus qui ne
fonctionne pas de façon durable
et donc c'est en partie ce qui explique
que la bourse qui était très qui avait
été extrêmement euphorique l'action en
Bourse avait été monté parce que le
business model de eDF leader mondial
apparaissait très porteur
cette image a été écornée quand on a vu
que EDF n'avait pas les moyens de
d'assurer l'autofinancement des
activités en France du fait que les
tarifs ne suivaient pas les tarifs sont
un peu remontés vous avez vu j'ai arrêté
de baissé les tarifs mais
pour ceux qui auraient pu être dans
l'article parce qu'il y avait pas mal de
presse juste avant mon départ j'avais eu
le malheur de dire que il faudrait à peu
près récupérer 20% de haute tarifaire en
3 ans ce qui fait ça en 4 ans ce qui
fait 5 % par an en gros ce qu'on avait
baissé dans les années précédentes et ça
fait un buzz et ça a contribué au fait
que alors que je pensais être doublé
j'ai pas été mais
j'ai quand même eu la satisfaction de de
à mon départ l'entreprise était
tout à fait saine
il restait encore à assurer le
que les tarifs suivraient le l'évolution
des investissements je peux préciser
aussi que l'entreprise a versé beaucoup
de dividendes à peu près un montant de 4
milliards et demi par an de dividendes
pour le pour l'État à l'essentiel 80% et
pour les actionnaires pour le pour le
sol
enfin
ce que je voudrais dire de cette époque
comme on voit pour comparer aujourd'hui
quel était l'état de l'opinion publique
et de la politique alors un on l'a
oublié aujourd'hui il y avait des
groupes antinucléaires
pas nombreux mais très violent on l'a
oublié c'est violence il y a eu des
violences avec des blessés
il aurait pu avoir des morts je crois
même qu'il y en a eu notamment avec
Chris Malville à Roscoff crespelville
c'est dans le Rhône c'était le
surgénérateur
Roscoff c'est un projet de développement
et mon prédécesseur Monsieur Marcel
Boiteux qui est toujours vivant qui
vient de fêter ses 100 ans a été l'objet
d'un attentat qui a beaucoup marqué il a
il a vraiment eu peur pour sa vie donc
il y avait noyau dur anti-nucléaire mais
en même temps
il y avait un consensus dans l'opinion
publique et compris dans les politiques
alors je vais vous raconter que ce
consensus comment vous pouvez le toucher
du doigt
d'abord personne ne parlait de nucléaire
c'était pas dans les la médias
et je pense que vous vous souvenez il y
a eu un débat pour les élections
présidentielles au deuxième tour entre
madame Ségolène Royal et Nicolas Sarkozy
au cours de ces débats
le présentateur l'aura les interrogés
pour savoir est-ce qu'ils savaient
qu'elle était la part du nucléaire dans
la production d'électricité en France
aucun des deux ne le savaient l'un a
répondu 80% eux pardon l'un a répondu 13
% et l'autre a répondu 50%
dis pas qu'elle est celui qui est lequel
elle a été 80 à l'époque on produisait
80% de l'électricité nucléaire qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'à cette
époque madame
Ségolène Royal et Nicolas Sarkozy avait
bien préparé leur dossier pour cet
affrontement
à l'époque l'énergie elle nucléaire est
à un sujet consensuel et il n'avait pas
imaginé qu'ils allaient devoir
s'affronter sur ce sujet
le
alors
aujourd'hui la dynamique de la relance
du nucléaire qui était initié en 2004 a
été cassé alors je veux dire
passer la parole je voulais vous dire un
peu pour terminer cette exposé et que
quand j'ai pas été renouvelé
bon j'ai été triste parce que j'étais
complètement persuadé que EDF était
parti pour être leader mondial et que le
jour où les prix électricité remonterait
la performance financière d'EDF serait
extrêmement brillante
la dynamique a été cassée
je pense que vous allez examiner au
cours de vos enquêtes quelle est la
raison de
de ce manque de soutien
à la filière nucléaire de cette abandon
aujourd'hui
je pense et ça je voudrais conclure
là-dessus et j'aimerais si je peux
formuler un souhait que vous me situez
mais surtout que ça fasse partie de
votre travaux je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
dynamique de la relance du nucléaire qui
a été cassée
la relance aujourd'hui est possible elle
est souhaitable et possible pourquoi
il y a beaucoup de points communs avec
la situation qui existait en 74
l'opinion publique le Pinot politique a
pris conscience des enjeux et après
conscience
qu'il fallait
que la France retrouve sa compétence
deuxièmement un moment on a vécu dans
l'idée qu'on avait plus besoin d'être
réciter que finalement on allait on a
même eu des scénarios de prévisions que
la consommation d'électricité elle est
baissée et donc on en disait il y a pas
besoin d'investir etc c'est fini
maintenant la rte médicaux qui sont plus
réalistes avec croissance de la
consommation prévoit dans les je crois
dans les 20 ans et 50% de croissance
c'est beaucoup plus réaliste
il nous reste à surmonter le déclin des
compétences
et la désindustrialisation de la France
il nous reste à surmonter ça mais
justement on peut y contribuer
alors on a des atouts aujourd'hui
on a appris bien sûr flamant ville est
un expérience extrêmement douloureuse
puisque on a eu beaucoup de retards et
de difficultés mais on apprend de ces
échecs aujourd'hui entre Flamanville
taille Chan hitle
on a des références
incidemment panli a été abandonné en
cours de route vous avez dit c'était la
deuxième centrale que je prévoyais mon
pronostic c'était si on avait lancé mon
lit deux ans après pour l'ISRA en
activité parce que tous les pépins qu'on
a eu sur Flamanville ont servi pour les
centrales suivantes il y a pas doute que
les Chinois à tihan ont bénéficié de des
pépins de Flamanville pour ne pas les
reproduire
deuxièmement donc on a une compétence et
le il y a un noyau de compétences mon
successeur je regarderai il y a pas
longtemps que si on n'avait pas fait
l'Angleterre probablement qu'il n'y
aurait plus le noyau de compétences en
France on l'a parce qu'il y a encore des
ingénieurs qui travaillent sur les
centrales en projet entre
icpoint et sagesse qui fait 4 centrales
en développement on a encore un noyau de
compétences c'est pas suffisant il faut
le développer en 2000
en 1974
quand Giscard était devant le plan
Messmer il y avait pas ses compétences
on les a bâtit en quelques années
les chinois ils ont fait Aïcha dans 7
ans
eux maintenant ils construisent 4 à 5
centrales par an donc ils ont ils ont
une filière industrielle très développée
c'est plus opportun a toujours de citer
les Russes mais
rosatum qui est quand même une société
des leaders mondiaux dans le nucléaire
30 ans après Tchernobyl et devenu je
sais pas si vous savez aujourd'hui c'est
le premier exportateur de centrales
nucléaire dans le monde aujourd'hui
alors c'est possible
trois conditions
1 il faut une fermeté vis-à-vis de
Bruxelles
pour que on puisse assurer le
financement par des contrats à long
terme et avec une garantie de l'État
c'est comme ça qu'on a faire dans le
Bretagne
la Grande-Bretagne l'a obtenu de
Bruxelles avec avec EDF on était aux
côtés la Grande-Bretagne l'abobtenir
pour le marché anglais nous n'avons pas
obtenu en France
j'ai d'ailleurs eu des juré la seule
raison qui justifie qu'on nationalise à
nouveau EDF
puisque on n'a pas été en mesure
d'obtenir les accords de financement
deuxième condition et puis également
revoir le Market design parce que le
système actuel de fixation des prix des
tarifs de l'électricité
est absurde parce que
soit les primes à des niveaux tels que
c'est insupportable pour le marché et ça
crée des rentes injustifiées soit il
descendent à des conditions telles que
plus personne n'investit donc il faut
trouver des mécanismes
c'est possible
c'est pas sûr qu'on arrive à au
consensus en France en Europe et ça ça
veut peut-être dire qu'il faudra
accepter qu'il y ait des différences
entre pays les conditions sont très
différentes d'un pays à l'autre
deuxièmement il faut accélérer les
procédures
du temps jusqu'à on a mis 7 ans
maintenant on dit qu'il faut 15 ans
c'est vrai aussi pour l'éolien on a
rajouté des procédures des débats des
concertations c'est légitime
mais il faut encadrer ça sinon on
n'arrivera pas à tenir les programmes de
relance de relance et que dans les
autres pays on a ils arrivent à
construire des centrales dans des délais
plus courts et enfin troisièmement c'est
l'essentiel
et c'est vous avez un rôle à jouer il
faut un engagement politique dans la
durée et détermine le nucléaire ne peut
pas redémarrer en cachette il ne peut
pas démarrer uniquement par l'équilibre
des forces du marché il faut un
engagement politique dans la durée
déterminée
merci beaucoup pour
ce premier propos fort complet déjà
mais avec le rapporteur nous sommes nous
commençons à être un peu aiguisé sur ces
sujets là certains de questions à vous
poser
d'abord il y a un sujet que que vous
n'avez pas abordé et qui qui m'intéresse
qui est la projection
à l'époque où vous dirigez EDF
de l'évolution du marché repeint
d'électricité comment est-ce que parce
que bon c'est la loi nomme qui arrive en
2010 qui crée l'impact en France mais
comment est-ce que vous vous prépariez à
ce moment là à ça et quels étaient les
risques que vous aviez identifié et
auquel vous avez essayé de vous dès
qu'elle vous avez essayé de vous
prémunir
alors
quand j'étais
à la tête d'EDF
les seuls aspects que j'ai eu à mettre
en œuvre et c'est ce concernant la
séparation entre les activités transport
distribution et production
[Musique]
bon l'activité distribution je dirais
c'était assez logique ça posait pas trop
de problèmes puis déjà on était habitués
à ça puisque il y avait déjà des régies
locales à Bordeaux Strasbourg qui avait
leur système donc je dirais la
séparation avec la distribution on doit
être un peu dommage parce que ça veut
dire aussi séparer de Gaz de France donc
il y avait
des économies d'échelle qui tombaient
mais également des révolutions
dans la distribution une grande partie
était liée à leur relève comme vous le
savez sans doute et qui est employé des
beaucoup de personnes et maintenant avec
avec les compteurs automatiques et les
10 c'est un aspect qui disparaît donc la
distribution posait pas de problème du
côté du transport le transport a aussi
la responsabilité de en permanence de
veiller à l'équilibre entre la
production et le marché
c'était outre son fonction transport
c'était sa deuxième fonction cette
deuxième était quand même très liée à
EDF puisque quand on
en permanence EDF doit planifier son
programme de production en tenant compte
de ce que va être le marché bon alors la
vérité c'est que EDF a créé en son sein
un espèce de
contrepartie de
je sais pas si vous l'avez visité ou si
vous avez entendu de de toute la partie
équilibre production vente il y a une
cellule au sein d'EDF qui et qui est en
dialogue permanent avec RTE pour
planifier si vous voulez pour comment
faire pour que DF conduit son parc pour
que ça permet de faire face à la
consommation donc EDF est obligé d'avoir
ça la séparation à l'époque m'avait paru
un peu dommage
c'était un peu du gaspillage bon on a
trouvé un moyen de de recréer et ça
fonctionne voilà
sinon c'est ça c'est pas au point de vue
financier il y a pas d'impact les
problèmes d'investissement de RTE
étaient
je pense pas qu'à aucun moment EDF était
conduit arbitré entre le transport et la
distribution entre le transport et la
production au détriment du réseau donc
je pense pas que ça a changé grand chose
maintenant c'est plus EDF qui a arbitre
c'est le régulateur puisque les
régulateur fixe les tarifs qui
permettent à RTE de
se rémunérer et les tarifs sont fixés en
fonction des investissements que RTE
prévoit puisque le modèle que j'ai
décrivé tout à l'heure qu'il fallait que
le cash flow au finance les
investissements s'applique complètement
pour le transport et c'est même par
nature c'est même la fonction de du
régulateur de fixer des tarifs qui
permettent de financer les
investissements donc de ce point de vue
ça a pas changé grand chose sur les
investissements c'était plus moi qui
arbitré c'était le régulateur mais avec
les mêmes critères donc ça ça changeait
pas grand chose sinon sur le marché on
était confiant puisque nous étions
convaincus que s'il y avait une
ouverture du marché PDF qu'elle est
gagnant puisqu'on avait les meilleurs
tarifs de d'Europe donc ça nous est
gênait pas par contre toute idée qui est
peut-être submant chez les concurrents
qui venaient avec la reine je peux vous
dire que quand j'en ai entendu parler là
j'ai hurlé j'ai jamais dit j'ai toujours
dit non la reine est une monstre et
monstruosité je sais pas si vous le
mesurer alors pourquoi on a mis la reine
c'est pas pas de mon temps hein
quand l'idée a été évoqué je hurlais
c'est absurde qu'est-ce qui justifie que
DF subventionne ses concurrents
alors je fais le l'avocat de adverse la
justification c'est de dire que DF a de
fait un monopole en ayant le coup du
nucléaire et que personne ne peut en
bénéficier et donc personne ne pourra
jamais investir dans ce domaine donc la
seule manière pour que les autres
puissent investir c'est qu'ils aient une
partie de la rente nucléaire voilà la
justification regardez aucun de ceux qui
ont bénéficié de la rente d'investi ni
dans le nucléaire ni dans même dans la
production
ou très peu sauf total qui a les moyens
qui a pas besoin de ça pour le faire
voilà donc c'est ce que je peux dire
l'ouverture du marché nous inquiétait
pas outre mesure puisqu'on disait si le
marché est vraiment ouvert
mais le problème c'est que Bruxelles
conscient de ça a introduit des pilules
empoisonnées pour empêcher EDF de
s'imposer sur le marché
la reine est une pilule empoisonnée
c'est une manière de d'empêcher eux
d'être de bénéficier de sa honte c'est
clair
donc je pense que la reine est quelque
chose
qu'on n'aurait jamais dû accepter alors
c'est c'est une collusion bruxelloise et
allemande parce que il faut savoir que
l'Allemagne a toujours été très
honnêtement le pouvoir politique
également était très
conscient que la France avait un
avantage
particuliers avec les prix d'électricité
bas et y compris l'industriellement
parce que à cette époque là j'ai pas dit
de mon temps les tarifs pratiqués par
EDF dans le pôle secteur domestique et
industriel était nettement inférieur à
ce qui se passait en Allemagne de
l'ordre de 30%. nettement inférieur et
donc Bruxelles et les Allemands
considérer que c'était une distorsion de
concurrence
merci
[Musique]
la période pendant laquelle vous
présidez EDF
et également celle pendant laquelle
sera lancée le Grenelle de
l'environnement si je ne me trompe
ou juste intérieur j'ai plus
le Grenelle de l'environnement qui
conclut notamment
à la au développement de plus tard on
appellera les Smart Grids l'intelligence
des réseaux de distribution la mise en
place
du compteur Linky notamment quelle est
la vision que vous faites à ce moment-là
de l'évolution des réseaux et notamment
dans la perspective de l'injection des
énergies nouvelles
renouvelables
intermittente comme comme elles ont
comme nom successifs
c'est plutôt
même mémoire c'est que on était plutôt
en soutien via c'était plutôt une
évolution qui nous paraissait naturel et
souhaitable
[Musique]
le
CET accompagné aussi il voulait pas dit
mais c'est ça va de pair aussi avec le
développement du renouvelable parce que
le
renouvelable
implique une gestion du réseau
très particulière puisque il est
intermittent donc
sa complexifie le métier de distributeur
et de transporteur de réseau donc ça
encore plus je veux dire il faut que le
réseau soit de plus en plus intelligent
pour arriver à être compatible avec le
renouvelable donc ça nous paraissait
quelque chose de souhaitable je me
souviens à mon époque que mon inquiétude
c'est pour ça que ça n'a pas été lancé
de bon temps je crois c'était lancé
après la question c'était de qui est une
stabilisation de la technologie parce
que on était encore dans une période où
les compteurs intelligents
évoluaient tous les ans comme les
smartphones et donc pour EDF et on a
fini par le faire ça c'est bien fait
d'ailleurs il faut stabiliser il faut
qu'on en a qu'un et donc
on n'était pas encore mais on savait que
ça allait venir on savait que ça allait
venir et ça finit par venir et
finalement c'est un succès honnêtement
j'y suis pour rien mais le je vois le
compteurs intelligents maintenant ils
sont là et
il y a encore quelques petites franges
de la population qui a peur des ondes
mais sinon ça marche bien et c'était
inéluctable et c'est absolument
nécessaire si on veut développer le
renouvelable
merci beaucoup quand vous avez beaucoup
parlé de de la l'état dans lequel vous
vous trouvez EDF en arrivant et
notamment de de l'absence
d'investissement depuis un certain temps
à quoi expliquer vous cette absence
d'investissement vous avez mon diagramme
1 premièrement il y a une raison tout à
fait logique et légitime qui était qui a
eu un effort colossal d'investissement
pour fabriquer le programme nucléaire et
que
ça a écraser tout donc que les les
investissements descendent après c'est
légitime deuxièmement
[Musique]
le l'effort qui a été fait là est inouïe
je veux dire même je fais une parenthèse
je l'ai pas raconté j'ai été en 2006 je
crois en Chine pour vendre la
participation de EDF pour développer
les centrales et le père et je rencontre
le Premier ministre qui est Monsieur
Vigneau
et
je lui dis monsieur le Premier ministre
actuellement la Chine construit qu'une
centrale nouvelle par an
et
chez l'état grand pays la France a tout
petit pays et on a fabriqué 5 par an
là il y a une interruption de séance le
Premier ministre est osé vers 16 sbire
pour savoir si ce que j'avais dit il
avait bien compris ce que j'avais dit
vous rendez compte 5 parents ont
construits et la c'est aujourd'hui je ne
sais même pas si on pourrait le refaire
aujourd'hui cinq parents alors
que je répondrai à votre question mais
ce que je veux dire pour l'avenir
c'était que deux montants déjà on
s'était dit pour le renouvellement du
parc il faut arriver à lisser
étaler parce qu'on peut pas on pourra
pas refaire sur 10 ans donc il faut
étaler et une des manières d'étaler
c'est de prolonger la durée de vie de
certaines centrales
pas toutes de la même durée donc on peut
étaler pour ce qui a été fait en disant
l'étalé sur 20 ans donc la
caractéristique de ce pic incroyable sur
10 ans c'était que toutes les centrales
étaient quasiment neuve et donc qu'il y
ait une chute des dépenses d'entretien
des centrales de maintenance et tout à
fait légitime elles étaient neuves quand
je suis arrivé elle commençait à être
moins neuve
donc voilà pour partie par contre que le
reste je ne sais pas là parce que j'ai
trouvé la même chose dans le thermique
et dans l'hydraulique mais dans le
nucléaire honnêtement j'ai recommencé
les investissements surtout d'ailleurs
dans la partie classique des centrales
c'était les générateurs les turbines etc
parce que tout ce qui était nucléaire
est complètement encadré par l'Autorité
de sûreté là les investissements ont
lieu je n'ai jamais eu le moindre doute
ni le montant ni avant ni après qu'il y
a eu des prises de risques en matière de
sûreté nucléaire et l'Autorité de sûreté
il veille elle fait bien son job donc il
y a pas quand je dis qu'on n'a pas assez
investi je pense qu'à aucun moment on a
menacé la circuit sécurité mais on a
menacé la productivité
alors quand vous arrivez aux affaires
premier réacteur de puissance
à neutrons rapide a été arrêté
quelle vision
avez-vous à cette époque-là quelle
vision est communément acceptée à cette
époque-là de du cycle du combustible et
de la nécessité d'envisager autre chose
que l'enrichissement de l'uranium
ces regrettable oui ça avait été c'est
Phénix qui avait été
crèche Malville avait été fermée juste
avant
et juste après d'ailleurs on a fermé
aussi
[Musique]
comment elle s'appelle cherche le nom
voilà c'est ça et donc c'est non c'est
très dommage
c'était le CEA avec lequel on avait des
relations
tout à fait complémentaires
simplement ce que il faut bien voir
c'est que pour EDF
l'horizon des surgénérateur était
forcément assez lointain pour la raison
que je viens de dire parce que
les sujets générateurs auraient pu se
substituer à la partie investissement
nouveau par contre
prolonger la durée de vie des centrales
existantes
ce qui veut dire allonger de 20 ans
c'était évidemment la priorité pour EDF
parce que c'est évidemment très rentable
donc c'était pas un sujet urgent mais on
y était très favorable bien sûr oui et
je regrette
ce qui s'est passé
à Chris Malville et regrettable le
l'arrêt a été fait pour des raisons
évidemment politique c'était un peu
satisfaire une certaine frange de
l'opinion mais il faut reconnaître que
c'était pas encore un succès industriel
ce n'était pas encore un succès
industriel donc c'était encore en phase
de recherche mais par contre ou en même
temps
c'est tout à fait regrettable qu'on est
quitté ça parce que je vous le disais on
était leader mondial et on peut pas être
leader mondial si on n'est pas à la
pointe de la recherche aujourd'hui les
surgénérateurs sont toujours une voie
d'amenir et cette voix on n'y est pas et
ça c'est très ennuyeux donc si je
reparle tout à l'heure j'ai dit tout à
l'heure qu'il fallait une volonté
politique je pense que ça en fait partie
redonner confiance dans cette filière et
il faut qu'on soit dans l'avenir si on
veut attirer les jeunes ingénieurs il
faut qu'il y ait des perspectives
d'avenir il suffit pas de dire qu'on
continue comme avant il faut aller vers
l'avenir et le surgénateur en fait
partie
et est-ce que c'était seulement une
réflexion sur la technologie d'avenir ou
est-ce qu'il y avait une réflexion
autour du cycle du combustible et de la
disponibilité
de l'uranium enrichi
écouter on avait
alors ça pose aussi la relation avec
[Musique]
Areva
nous avions un stock qu'on avait on
m'avait dit qu'on avait un stock de
d'uranium d'environ 15 ans c'est l'ordre
de grandeur
donc on était jamais
c'était pas une préoccupation de court
terme par contre j'avais
pas évoqué tout à l'heure dans ma
politique de renaissance du nucléaire là
j'avais mis comme objectif
de sécuriser l'approvisionnement en
uranium
et mon idée c'était un peu ce que
j'avais développé pour le gaz j'avais
dit il faut à la fois être sur le marché
parce que EDF est mais il faut que nous
investissions nous-mêmes dans des mines
et j'en avais parlé à rêva ça n'a pas eu
de suite
mais c'était pour le long terme nous
étions sécurisé sur 15 ans et je disais
il faut qu'on ait une maîtrise du coup
c'était surtout sur le coup à la durée
de vie d'une centrale une centrale ça
dure 60 ans on avait une vision à 15 ans
et donc je souhaitais consolider sur une
vision à long terme en ayant une partie
d'actifs ce n'est pas le cas enfin
il va
[Musique]
la compétence pour assurer cette
sécurité
je laisserai le rapporteur revenir plus
plus en détail sur les sujets autour
d'Areva j'aurais une dernière série de
questions sur le lancement des des EPR
enfin de le père finalement français
vous êtes aux affaires quand la décision
de lancer flamme en ville est prise
donc une question sur sur ces éléments
c'est la première fois du coup en France
avec Flamanville qu'on ne lance qu'un
seul chantier et non deux en parallèle
pourquoi ce pourquoi ce choix et cette
proposition technique là vous avez
raison c'est sans doute regrettable
à l'expérience la raison c'était que
comme je vous l'ai dit on est en
surcapacité et que j'avais un peu vendu
le projet pour dire c'est une manière de
retrouver des compétences c'est comme ça
que je l'ai vendu et allez dire qu'on en
faisait deux j'aurais encore plus de mal
voilà
et mais l'expérience monte parce qu'en
Angleterre on le fait mais en Angleterre
il y a pas de surcapacité donc les
chantiers dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
que ça soit une clépoint ou SiWay on les
fait par paire et en effet j'ai eu des
retours de mes collègues qui me disent
il y a pas d'autres qu'en faisant une
paire ça coûte moins cher que d'en faire
deux fois
et
du coup pourquoi est-ce que à votre avis
pas en ligne n'a pas encore été lancé
jusque-là vous vous évoquez le fait que
c'était finalement dans le plan de
départ de de Flamanville de lancer assez
vite après panli pourquoi cette décision
n'a pas été prise
je
ça c'est délité je ne sais pas très bien
j'étais pas
aux commandes qu'est-ce qui peut
justifier de pas l'avoir fait toujours
que il n'y avait pas de besoin à court
terme c'est clair
la situation de DFC dégradé parce que le
l'histoire de la reine là
cette pilule empoisonnée
ça
très sérieusement remis en cause le
business model d'EDF qui qui n'avait
plus les moyens de de faire des
investissements non immédiatement
rentable il est certain que de créer une
surcapacité
c'est ça le sujet de la réglementation
du tarif
si on veut pas avoir de pénurie il faut
avoir une surcapacité c'est de la même
manière que si vous voulez être sûr
d'être à l'heure un rendez-vous il faut
vous y prenez à l'avance donc si on veut
pas avoir de pénurie il faut une
surcapacité
le bécanisme le marché n'incite pas à la
surcapacité parce que c'est les temps
longs l'investissement et donc à partir
du moment où vous avez la concurrence
sur le marché la pression sur les prix
personne n'a envie de bâtir une
surcapacité et donc le fait que le
marché soit ouvert à certainement
dégradé
l'intérêt pour EDF de lancer Pandi dans
les mêmes délais certainement
parce que pour lui on pourrait pas
justifier par une rentabilité immédiate
de police puisqu'il y avait une sur
capacité
c'est le rapporteur
voilà le rapporteur ne bénéfice pas du
même privilège au niveau du micro que le
président donc falloir que vous coupiez
le vôtre pour qu'il puisse parler que
vous le rallumer à chaque fois pour
prendre la parole
merci monsieur le Président je reprends
exactement au point où on s'arrête sur
la surcapacité parce que il faut que
vous nous expliquiez quelque chose qu'on
que j'ai du mal à comprendre deux choses
première question est-ce que vous
convenez qu'en fait à l'époque
contrairement d'ailleurs à aujourd'hui
on avançait à l'aveugle en termes de
projection de consommation d'énergie et
de consommation d'électricité
aujourd'hui par exemple on dispose de
RTE d'autres organismes qui sont plus ou
moins sérieux plus ou moins rigoureux
mais qui en tout cas font des
projections de consommation
d'électricité qui s'appuie sur des
usages sur des évolutions de la
consommation d'énergie primaire finale
etc à vous entendre on disposait
visiblement pas de la même capacité de
projection je vous dis pourquoi je vous
demande ça on était quand même à une
époque où on venait de on allait
inscrire dans le bloc de
constitutionnalité la Charte de
l'environnement on avait une
reconnaissance mondiale progressive et
française importante de l'importance du
un changement climatique et donc de
l'importance de sortir des énergies
fossiles et malgré ça on arrivait dans
un raisonnement où on pouvait penser
qu'on serait en surcapacité de
production d'électricité alors que 1 on
peut exporter de l'électricité et que
deux a priori c'était quand même la
seule solution à court terme au moyen
terme réalise de sortir de la
consommation d'énergie fossiles donc à
la fois sur les outils qui étaient à la
disposition des pouvoirs publics et des
entreprises comme EDF et puis sur le
contexte général de ce mode surcapacité
est-ce que vous pourriez nous en dire un
peu plus
alors quand je parlais sur capacité
c'est factuel c'est à dire que au moment
de je vous parle
le marché était environ
enfin la capacité de production était
d'environ 20% supérieur à notre
consommation et ça sera divisé par le
fait qu'il y avait des unités à
l'arrière
notamment les unités thermiques il y
avait la priorité du nucléaire nucléaire
fonctionnait toujours mais les unités
thermiques étaient souvent l'arrêt et
deuxièmement qu'on exportait on
exportait de l'ordre de 60
toujours supérieur à 50 km pour un
marché de 500 donc on exportait en gros
net quand je dis 50 c'est le net c'est à
dire environ 10% du marché oui c'est
notre notre soldenet d'exportation
pendant les 10 ans pendant les 5 ans où
j'étais aux commandes et les gens qui
ont suivi étaient elles-mêmes donc la
surcapacité on peut pas la nier elle est
dans les faits elle est dans les
chiffres 10% à peu près c'est en gros
10% bon ceci étant l'Europe était RA
puisque c'est EDF qui a qui faisait le
les fans du consommateur européen en
général et allemand en particulier et
d'ailleurs si aujourd'hui il y a un
problème en Europe c'est parce que cette
surcapacité que nous avions la plus
cette capacité d'exportation c'est pas
quand je dis sur capacité d'ailleurs le
mot est vous avez raison sur un point
c'est qu'il faudrait maintenant nuancer
ça parce que quand je parlais je parlais
de sur capacité par rapport au marché
français
voilà alors quand vous parlez au niveau
européen c'est un sens complètement
différent en effet puisque au niveau
européen
je dirais que c'est les
l'évolution des prix et des prix
relatifs des des outils de production
qui peut faire la différence
bien que ça soit biaisé comme vous le
savez puisque même si vous le nucléaire
est moins cher par moment on donne la
priorité
renouvelable
d'ailleurs se justifie mais bon c'est un
fait donc là c'était en fait bon
deuxième remarque non non EDF avait les
outils et d'ailleurs comme je vous l'ai
dit on faisait partie donc de mon temps
RTE qui fait toutes ces projections
faisaient partie de la maison donc on
avait on avait tout à fait les outils
mais plutôt français c'est vrai
le débat a changé à partir du moment on
a ouvert le marché parce qu'à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce que c'est que la
surcapacité au niveau européen c'est
beaucoup plus difficile à mesurer
honnêtement beaucoup plus difficile
parce que ça dépend de la compétitivité
des différentes formes de production
enfin troisième remarque que je vais
vous faire c'est qu'avec ce
cette période
que ça soit à Bruxelles ou dans les
certains milieux français
il y a eu cette illusion cette illusion
mais
impression ou cette conviction
qu'on pouvait par un
comportement sobre réduire la
consommation d'énergie ça a été un thème
très fort et si vous voulez EDF qui
avait ses propres modèles s'est battu je
peux vous le dire contre des d'autres
modèles et notamment même le RTE quand
il était indépendant à sortir un moment
des modèles où il y avait une réduction
de la consommation d'électricité
ça n'est jamais apparu il y a eu des
débats je pouvais retrouver il y a eu
des confrontations à feutrés mais EDF a
toujours compté le fait qu'on pourrait
imaginer une baisse de la consommation
électricité alors les stables elle s'est
stabilisée mais EDF a toujours plaidé je
crois on peut pas à la fois dire qu'on
veut développer les applications de
consommation qui épargne la production
de CO2 comme la voiture électrique comme
le chauffage électrique et dire qu'on va
baisser la consommation électricité le
les modèles est maintenant il y a ça
évolue bien le les nouveaux modèles du
RTE que j'ai vu récemment me paraissent
beaucoup plus réaliste mais on peut pas
imaginer que c'était
cette évolution vers la réduction des
émissions de CO2 qui est tout à fait
souhaitable puis se faire sans que la
part de l'électricité augmente dans la
dans le la consommation électricité dans
la consommation d'énergie on pense
aujourd'hui si vous voulez les chiffres
comme ça des ordres de grandeur que j'ai
en tête que la consommation
de mondial d'énergie pourrait être
de
stabiliser ou lors de 1% par an et la
consommation d'électricité au moins de
2,5% par an et en France c'est encore
plus
l'électricité la part de l'électricité
dans la consommation totale d'énergie et
là il y a un consensus va augmenter
parce que les les
centrales thermiques ne fonctionnaient
qu'en pointe donc en base
la base était déjà excédentaire et on a
été conduit à faire ce qui est pardon
j'ai oublié de dire ça effectivement et
ça aurait répondu plus directement à
votre question EDF a été obligé de faire
quelque chose qui n'est pas optimal
dans le monde c'est-à-dire de d'arrêter
ces centrales nucléaires je sais pas si
vous en a parlé normalement une centrale
nucléaire pour fonctionner au meilleur
rendement elle fonctionne à temps plein
sans arrêt
sauf quand on l'arrêt pour pour changer
le combustible EDF a été obligé contenu
de la surcapacité même en dehors des
pointes
à réduire la production d'électricité
nucléaire ce qui est pas du tout optimum
sur le plan économique et pour le faire
EDF a inventé on est les seuls au monde
à le faire on réduit la production on
module la production centrale nucléaire
ce qui est probablement une des causes
des difficultés que nous avons
aujourd'hui parce que probablement ça
use les centrales plus que un
fonctionnement en continu
vous savez il y a un taux
d'indisponibilité que nous avons et
probablement que c'est la cause
parce que les mêmes centrales aux
États-Unis ils sont les mêmes elles ont
un meilleur taux de distribué ça m'avait
frappé quand j'étais aux commandes parce
que j'avais vu les centrales américaines
elles étaient beaucoup plus disponibles
que les nôtres et la réponse de Vegas
c'était dire mais oui mais eux ne
modulent pas
donc voilà une sanction concrète que la
surcapacité avait une sanction
économique ce n'était pas le petit homme
je remercie je passe le Pr
en gardant un lien avec la surcapacité
parce que ce que vous avez dit forcément
nous a mis les puces à l'oreille on est
dans un monde où il y a globalement une
surcapacité et donc où il n'y a pas
d'argument selon vous objectif ce qui
concerne la production d'électricité
pour construire un nouveau réacteur pour
en France bien sûr pardon pour autant
vous voilà pour autant vous plaidez
auprès des pouvoirs publics pour la
construction d'un nouveau réacteur
avec l'argument de dire c'est la seule
manière de préserver les compétences
est-ce que c'est bien ce que vous avez
dit est-ce que c'était la seule manière
de préserver les compétences et dans ce
cas
pardonnez-moi d'un statut mais je trouve
ça un petit peu étonnant de dire que la
seule manière de préserver les
compétences c'était de construire
réacteur dont l'état des connaissances
actuelles ne permettait pas de dire
qu'on allait en avoir un besoin
aujourd'hui compétences c'est de
reconstituer une filière industrielle
parce que ce que
j'ai exposé c'était que
je l'ai là si vous voulez nous avions
prévu et je vais vous donner parce que
apparemment vous tournez toujours autour
de cette question nous avions une vision
très claire de ce qu'il fallait investir
dans les 30 ans qui viennent pas très
clair très précis et peut-être pas clair
mais pas juste mais tu es précise et ça
pour le faire il faut un outil
industriel et donc si on ne prenait pas
des mesures nous n'aurions pas eu
l'outil industriel et pour constituer
cet outil industriel vous pouvez pas
payer des gens à ne rien faire il faut
qu'il soit
occupé et en plus c'est une manière de
d'exporter ses compétences puisque
mon analyse était que je pensais que le
nucléaire allait repartir dans d'autres
pays
et donc il fallait créer une filière
capable d'exporter et donc le fait que
il fallait une centrale en France c'est
que je pense qu'il était très difficile
de pouvoir vendre une centrale à
l'étranger si on en avait pas une chez
nous voilà donc le famonville si vous
voulez c'était une manière et d'ailleurs
les Chinois
souvent les Chinois ont fini par faire
les élèves ont fini par faire mieux que
le maître mais les Chinois il y avait
des délégations chinois qui étaient
affamanville les Chinois étaient
totalement associés à la construction de
Flamanville totalement et tous les
pépins qu'on a eu il les connaissait et
ils en ont tiré conséquence donc ça a
été pour nous un argument pour vendre le
nucléaire aussi bien en Chine que quand
Grande-Bretagne donc c'est pour ça c'est
pas
et d'ailleurs flamobil ne suffit pas à
occuper la filière et aujourd'hui
heureusement heureusement
il y a la plupart des ingénieurs
travaillent pas sur flamboy maintenant
parce que flamboïs c'est fini un point
de vue ingénierie on a des pépins à
frapper il travaille sur Facebook sur
inclipoid et ça se voit travaille sur
les quatre
mais je pense qu'on aurait jamais eu une
époque et Siwel si on n'avait pas une
femme en ville et ni la Chine ça c'est
sûr
dans ce que vous dire ce que vous dites
après je passe à autre chose mais pour
être sûr d'avoir bien compris c'est que
l'argument majeur qui a motivé la
lancement de la construction du de le
père de Flamanville c'est le maintien
d'une filière industrielle crédible à
l'export
industriel tout court et que l'export
est un des moyens de l'avoir si vous
voulez l'export était
une retombée l'export mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que si on n'avait pas
fait ça on n'aurait pas eu la filière
industrielle quand on en avait besoin
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui
merci je passe au contexte à l'heure de
la de la décision et puis du lancement
je lis deux lignes du rapport de la Cour
des comptes de 2020
qui évoque les rivalités entre deux
groupes publics nationaux arriva et EDF
et qui écrit dans la synthèse du rapport
c'est dans ces conditions qui arrivent à
signer en 2003 un contrat de vente d'un
EPS électrice c'est un finlandais et que
DF a des 2004 la construction du premier
repère en France cette course entre les
deux entreprises françaises a conduit au
lancement précipité des chantiers de
construction de ces deux premiers EPR
sur la base de référence technique
erronées et d'études détaillées
insuffisantes et le rapport c'est
ensuite un certain nombre de références
j'en note simplement deux pour
illustrations je note dès que dans la
durée initiale de de construction du
réacteur prévu était je crois d'une
cinquantaine de mois contre une moyenne
de 120 mois de délai de construction en
moyenne dans les d'après la Cour des
comptes dans les années précédentes et
un deuxième chiffre il était à l'époque
prévu 5 millions d'heures de travail et
à l'heure du rendu du à la date de rendu
de rapport de la Cour des comptes on
avait une estimation à 22 millions
d'heures comment est-ce que vous
appréciez les deux sujets un peu
différents que j'ai mentionné d'abord la
temporalité de la prise de décision avec
une potentielle rivalité non productive
avec Areva et puis ensuite les
références techniques de départ qui ont
présidé au choix et à la date butoir de
construction de l'EPR
bon sur les délais
par rapport à ce qui ont été prévu et la
réalité c'est effectivement une
erreur d'appréciation totale qui est la
même du côté d'Areva que du côté de Depp
puisque
le qui lui auto a eu autant de retard si
ce n'est plus que que Flamanville donc
c'est pareil donc là il y avait une
erreur alors je vais vous dire là-dessus
ma conviction sur cette histoire de
dérapage
pourquoi pourquoi il y a des tels
dérapages je pense que vous allez
approfondir ça en voyant les les
gestionnaires qui ont géré ça
mais par rapport à ce que j'imaginais
c'est clair que j'avais pas imaginé ça
c'est clair alors il y a plusieurs
observations que je veux faire qui
peuvent contribuer à la réponse 1
j'étais conscient
qu'on était en train de perdre des
compétences parce qu'on n'est pas
construit de centrale depuis longtemps
et clairement le la compétence nucléaire
et quelque chose de très pointu et qui
touche il faut pas voir que c'est pas
que les ingénieurs nucléaires de def
c'est aussi les sous-traitants les
soudeurs enfin c'est toute la filière là
je vais vous dire le premier pépin que
j'ai eu qui m'a mis la puce à l'oreille
et j'ai compris que ça allait être pas
une longue partie de plaisir
j'ai commencé les travaux de femmes en
ville
et ça commençait par la partie
génie civile on a installé les murs en
béton
et bien j'ai été encore présent d'EDF on
a eu des problèmes dans les murs en
béton
en défaut parce que il avait pas
respecté les normes nucléaires qui
étaient une densité droit à béton qui
était imposée parce qu'il a pas fait ça
depuis très longtemps bon et ça si vous
voulez quand j'ai vu ça sur les ronds en
béton qui est un truc banal et pas du
tout pointu je me suis dit ça veut dire
que la machine est rouillée et que ça va
être dur de relancer la machine donc
voilà sur les délais et c'est
malheureusement ce qui s'est passé aussi
bien en Finlande que Flamanville donc
voilà pour le une des explications la
deuxième explication
c'est qu'on est dans un domaine je sais
pas si vous savez j'ai encore des
responsabilités dans le domaine de
l'aéronautique
et il y a une analogie entre
l'aéronautique et le nucléaire qui est
que les problèmes de sûreté sont
prioritaires c'est vrai dans le
nucléaire c'est vrai dans
les problèmes de sûreté ça veut dire que
toute changement toute modification
est infiniment plus compliqué plus
coûteuse qu'on ne le croyait regardez
Boeing avec ses et là si vous voulez on
s'est dit Areva comme EDF puisque enfin
je pense que vous savez qu'à l'époque en
gros l'ingénierie était moitié EDF
moitié
Eva c'est à peu près la même nombre
d'ingénieurs des deux côtés ils
travaillent ensemble et
ils ont complètement sous-évalués le
coût les délais et les difficultés d'une
modification ils sont dit ça ressemble à
ce qu'on faisait avant c'est pas très
différent donc voilà ça devrait pas
coûter plus que ça le changement est
beaucoup plus coûteux que prévu
d'ailleurs un moment je dois dire
quand j'ai lancé le Pr le le Flamanville
certains EDF me disaient revenons à
l'ancien modèle
amélioré plutôt que de faire un EPR qui
est très innovant j'avais déjà eu des
alertes bon
le coup était parti et quand même
beaucoup d'investissement avaient déjà
été fait alors maintenant EDF vis-à-vis
de Framatome enfin d'arriver à l'époque
oui c'est regrettable
je l'ai beaucoup regretté
j'ai souhaité
j'avais souhaité que nous travaillons
ensemble ce qui était le cas initial
puisque quand EDF est
nationalisé
et fera bateau aussi donc pratiquement
il travaille ensemble
Areva c'était mis avait développé un
business model à l'époque
qui était de séparer la partie
construction de la partie exploitation
de dire ces deux métiers différents
alors que avant c'était je vais vous
dire en gros moitié-moitié il y avait
autant d'ingénieurs du côté de
l'ingénierie d'EDF que l'ingénieur du
côté de la rêve et là Areva a dit on va
faire un business model et nous allons
vendre des centrales clés en main
sans EDF et le critère c'était qu'il
fallait surtout pas qu'il y a EDF et
donc le business model pour vendre
holkili auto ça a été de dire on ne veut
pas de DF je l'ai regretté clairement et
du coup je quand je vous cite les
retombées pour EDF il y en a pas Dolce
alors qu'il pourrait y avoir mais il y
en a pas par contre on en Aïcha on en a
de inkipoint on en a de partout on en a
pas de quel auto ou très peu un peu
quand même parce qu'il y a des
fournisseurs communs un peu quand même
mais enfin très peu je le regrette en
effet
mais c'est fini ça je veux dire ça a été
reconstitué depuis c'est une bonne une
bonne évolution
je vous remercie est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres exemples que vous voulez nous
donner sur les difficultés de
coopération parce que dans le rapport de
la Cour des comptes que je citais le la
synthèse évoque des rivalités non
productives entre les deux non arbitré
par la puissance publique nous avions
mentionné par exemple votre tentative de
d'investir dans les mines et la
discussion que vous avez eu auprès
d'arbat donc est-ce que vous avez
d'autres exemples à nous donner
premièrement et deuxièmement est-ce que
vous souscrivez à l'idée qu'il n'y a pas
eu d'arbitrage des pouvoirs publics et
et si c'est le cas comment ça s'est
matérialiser le fait qu'il n'y a pas eu
si ce n'est d'intervention du moins de
médiation de la part des pouvoirs
publics
non c'est vrai qu'il y a pas eu
d'arbitrage par contre
il y a eu
l'intelligence des hommes et des femmes
parce que la vérité c'est que sur les
chantiers ils travaillent ensemble je
peux témoigner
et que pour ma part je me suis toujours
évité
j'ai pris acte du fait que à Evan
souhaitait pas que des
soit associé à ces démarches
commerciales mais de fait puisque c'est
quand même moi qui ai passé les comme
les marchés que ça soit en Angleterre
aux États-Unis d'ailleurs mais en Chine
et Areva est venue après ça a été sans
problème
mais
le business model qui était de dire on
vend clé en main et sans EDF le seul
exemple c'est eux qui lui auto et voilà
mais je l'ai regretté et j'ai tout fait
pour que ce n'est pas de conséquence
voilà
et honnêtement et je pense que les
pouvoirs publics étaient dans cette
attitude c'est-à-dire ils avaient
compris ils étaient pas idiot il avait
compris et ils essayaient de faire en
sorte que
ce n'est pas de conséquence de majables
alors l'histoire de Flamanville
non on l'a pas du tout décidé dans la
précipitation ça c'est inexact puisque
je vous ai dit pourquoi on a décidé
j'étais pas dans l'urgence mais c'est
fait que c'était pour crédibiliser le
business model on n'était pas
dans l'urgence par contre ce qui est
vrai que je regrette c'est qu'on n'a pas
eu les retomber de l'auto ça c'est vrai
oui ça je le regrette
merci une dernière question sur le père
de Flamanville la décision politique est
prise en périnée par une loi en 2004
mais la décision va l'autorisation de
créer
une installation nucléaire de base
flamant ville et prise par un décret du
10 avril 2007 c'est à dire à l'extrême
limite
du quinquennat qui était en train de
s'achever est-ce que vous avez souvenir
qu'une décision qui ait eu dans les
arcades administratives et puis
forcément j'imagine en lien avec EDF une
décision qui soit prise juste avant un
éventuel une éventuelle alternance
politique en tout cas un changement de
Premier ministre et est-ce que ça est-ce
que c'est à dire qu'il y avait des
craintes qu'une majorité suivante ne ne
poursuivent pas l'engagement ne
concrétise pas l'engagement politique de
construire un EPS à Flamanville
j'ai pas pris conscience de ce que vous
dites vous m'en faites prendre
conscience
oui peut-être je demande en tous les cas
c'est pas ça qui m'a motivé je m'en
souviens plus mais c'est possible que
certains y pensaient mais conseillé de
faire ça
encore une fois ce que je vous dis
c'était que
la prise de conscience que le nucléaire
pouvait être mis en cause
je vous dis ça parce qu'en fait en avril
dans le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle le porte-parole du Parti
socialiste avait dit que le Pr était
inutile et dangereux honnêtement je vous
dis je réfléchis j'essaie de
j'étais pas préparé à cette question non
mais j'essaie de retrouver le calendrier
les premières alertes sur la remise en
cause du programme nucléaire ne date pas
de cette époque là la vraie première
alerte pour moi elle était après mon
départ
c'est quand le président Hollande
a annoncé qu'on allait arrêter les
centrales alors il a dit pas toutes
la moitié ou je sais pas quoi mais il a
annoncé officiellement qu'on allait
arrêter de développer le programme
nucléaire et c'est là l'alerte alors il
y avait eu avant l'accord entre
socialiste et partie écologique qui
était juste avant mais c'était en
[Musique]
2000 c'est bien après donc vraiment là
non alors maintenant ça me revient on
n'avait pas la moindre inquiétude encore
à cette époque non le ce que je reviens
à mon débat vous souvenez du débat dont
je parle c'était 2006 et là le débat
clairement le nucléaire n'était pas un
sujet sa passionnait personne ce que je
voudrais revenir là-dessus parce que
c'est c'est une leçon en Angleterre
c'est comme ça aujourd'hui vous regardez
Dieu sait si le champ politique en
Angleterre et chahuté sur l'énergie
c'est un consensus on en parle pas il y
a une agence très forte je vous le
signale il y a une agence qui s'occupe
d'énergie et de l'industrie qui est très
puissante en Angleterre qui qui éclaire
le aussi bien le Parlement que le que le
gouvernement et qui est suivi et il y a
toutes les alternances poétiques on
remet pas en cause la stratégie aux
États-Unis aussi aux États-Unis regardez
le nucléaire n'est pas un sujet c'est il
y a un consensus
et donc on était jeune non je corrige il
y a peut-être eu des gens qui ont pensé
mais moi je reviens non j'avais pas le
moindre inquiétude sur qu'on puisse
remettre en doute le programme nucléaire
honnêtement je n'y pensais pas vous
dites que vous inquiétudes remontent
seuls enfin n'arrive que au moment de
les déclarations du gouvernement après
2012 sur la question de l'arrêt
directeur etc mais vous êtes président
de DF jusqu'en 2009
à cette époque le réacteur enfin le Pr
était censé être prévu devait être
rentré en fonction pour 2012 mais
j'imagine qu'en 2009 on commence à se
dire que 2012 est un peu ambitieux de
2009 à 2019 depuis 2009 pardon vous êtes
président d'honneur d'électricité de
France c'est pas dans quelle mesure vous
avez des échanges avec les autorités
mais j'imagine que le fait qu'il n'y ait
pas de nouvelles décisions de construire
un nouveau réacteur ou bien notre pr ou
de poursuivre des recherches et le fait
que le retard s'accumule provoque des
inquiétudes est-ce que vous vous en
ouvrez au pouvoir public auprès d'EDF
mais au-delà enfin auprès de au sein de
du conseil d'administration d'EDF auprès
de l'agence participation de l'État
est-ce que vous allez voir le
gouvernement les ministres vous êtes
notamment membres en qualité en qualité
de personnalité
qualifiée à partir de enfin vous êtes
renouvelé en 2006 au CEA vous êtes vous
participez aux vous participez à la
commission d'experts mis en par Eric
Besson ministre de l'Industrie en 2012
pour élaborer des scénarios énergétiques
est-ce que vous n'avez pas avant la date
que vous évoquez des inquiétudes et
est-ce que vous les formuler au pouvoir
public
des formuler
[Musique]
les dirigeants actuels de l'entreprise
donc j'ai des contacts avec les
dirigeants actuels de dirigeants de
l'entreprise j'ai gardé beaucoup de
contacts
comme vous pouvez le noter j'ai passé
plus de 20 ans entre EDF et GDF donc je
suis très attaché à cette entreprise et
donc j'ai des contacts et je mesure bien
les inquiétudes qui sont les leurs j'ai
chaque fois je me suis manifesté chaque
fois j'ai eu la parole je peux même vous
laisser si vous voulez un article que
j'ai fait il y a
c'est plus récent il y a six mois où je
dis à la fois mes inquiétudes et le fait
que
je reviens là-dessus parce que
je pense qu'un choc comme celui qu'on a
actuellement
les difficultés qu'on a aujourd'hui il y
a celles qu'on vient de dettes mais il y
a aussi des des aspects externes il faut
pas le nier le fait que les pépins d'EDF
actuellement qui qui boit ça capacité de
production amputée de santé à wattheure
c'est à dire 20% de sa production c'est
que le sol mais ça arrive justement à un
moment où il y avait une crise de
l'énergie en Europe si s'il y avait eu
comme on était il y a deux ans un
excédent de capacité personne ne
l'aurait vu donc il y a des conséquences
externes mais c'est vrai que je continue
à penser que ce choc peut être salutaire
si on en tire les conclusions que
il faut recréer une dynamique et que ces
dynamiques doit être
soutenu politiquement dans la fermeté et
dans la stabilité voilà
je pense que d'un malheur quelque chose
de bon peut sortir
je vous remercie effectivement la
commission Besson avec les dés pour une
poursuite et renforcement du nucléaire
qui avait rendu ses travaux entre
septembre et janvier 2012
je ne vais pas
étonné
deux dernières questions
peut-être directement parce que vous
l'avez évoqué de vous-même sur sur la
question de la fermeture des réacteurs
et l'inquiétude que ça vous a provoqué
ce que vous dites c'est votre première
grande alerte
et vous dites dans une interview à Radio
Classique oui on a fait un peu de
d'archéologie en octobre 2014 vous dites
cette loi cette loi de Ségolène Royal
ministre de l'écologie sur la transition
énergétique est une noix de compromis
qui devait prendre en compte les
attentes de certaines sensibilités
écologistes et celles des consommateurs
qui a et attendait une énergie
compétitive et pas trop coûteuse je vais
un peu plus loin les objectifs définis
sont justifiés et légitimes
ça me semble un tout petit peu
contradictoire avec la très grande
inquiétude de fermer les réacteurs
je pense que
à l'époque comme aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
je souhaite ne rien dire qui gêne
l'entreprise ça a été vraiment mon souci
numéro 1 je suis extrêmement rattaché à
l'entreprise et je ne veux jamais rien
dire qu'il puisse apparaissent comme
polémique et si vous voulez pour que ça
fonctionne ce modèle
qui était EDF il faut je le pense je
l'ai vécu une confiance
total entre l'entreprise et le
gouvernement il ne peut pas y avoir de
différence
et donc j'ai toujours été attaché à ne
jamais publiquement affiché de désaccord
avec le gouvernement je pense que ça a
été l'attitude de Monsieur Jean-Bernard
Lévy
et donc je fais attention quand je
m'exprime à ne pas gêner ça voilà
deuxième remarque
mes propos ont été souvent interprétés
parce que j'ai dit que trouver un
équilibre à 55 ans entre
nucléaire et renouvelable paraît sans
doute une
attitude de raisonnable aujourd'hui je
l'ai dit c'est vrai je pense qu'on l'a
interprété en disant mais donc je suis
prêt à réduire bah non évidemment que
non et voilà
c'est les deux commentaires que je peux
faire mais sinon aujourd'hui je pense
qu'à gouvernement et je vois c'est ce
que font les Anglais les si on regardait
ce que font les Anglais aujourd'hui ils
disent on va mettre la moitié en
nucléaire la moitié en
renouvelable surtout de l'éolien c'est
un discours peut-être qu'un jour on doit
le remettre en cause mais au moins on
s'y tient et depuis 10 ans ils disent la
même chose et
si je pouvais avoir une influence c'est
celle-là que j'aimerais avoir
bien merci monsieur le rapporteur madame
poundiref pas de question madame Dufour
je prends dans l'ordre des groupes
politiques ça marche
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
on les a on les a
un peu à des propos que vous avez évoqué
monsieur le rapporteur plutôt c'est
est-ce que on avait une vision de
l'avenir oui alors sans l'arrêt sans
arrêt j'avais une vision l'année alors
là on en a une et je vais vous la
montrer c'était c'est amusant parce que
c'est un document que j'ai retrouvé qui
date de 2009 et qui était le document
dont je me servais pour convaincre les
pouvoirs publics qu'il fallait faire des
hausses tarifs et ce document décrit tel
que nous le voyons le programme des
investissements à venir jusqu'en 2020
avec à la fois ce que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est-à-dire
la durée de vie ce que on a appelé
maintenant grand carénage de montant la
plaie pas encore carénage et le nouveau
nucléaire et d'étaler le nouveau
nucléaire voilà
je pense que ça complet ce que je vous
ai donné pardon
aucun souci alors j'ai plusieurs
questions
donc la première c'est donc on parle
beaucoup de d'un système nucléaire qui
était en surcapacité aujourd'hui bon
manifestement cet hiver pour des
questions conjoncturelles il ne l'est
plus en dehors de la corrosion sous
contrainte qui est un accident on va
dire découvert dans des réacteurs plutôt
récents la le calendrier de la
maintenance pour les autres réacteurs
donc qui était aussi à l'arrêt est-ce
que cette situation d'arrêt donc d'une
partie des réacteurs en dehors de ce de
pour corrosion son contrainte aurait pu
être évité par davantage
d'investissement concernant la
maintenance traditionnelle de la barre
d'EDF et si oui vu que vous avez quand
même pointé à plusieurs reprises la
question de la reine est-ce que la reine
est un des facteurs principaux de ces
investissements qui auraient été
retardés ça c'était ma première question
deuxième donc dans le graphique très
intéressant que vous nous avez transmis
on voit donc à partir de 2002 le prix
d'électricité sont deux coups en dessous
en fait des investissements réalisés par
EDF donc j'imagine que c'était un prix
imposé par l'État si vous pouvez revenir
un peu là-dessus pendant cette période
vous avez parlé des dividendes qui
étaient versées par EDF et DF à ses
actionnaires notamment principalement à
l'état est-ce que pendant la période où
le prix de l'électricité était en
dessous de vos investissements EDF
continuaient à verser des dividendes
justement cette période on arrive à
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi norme vu
que vous étiez en train de faire des
investissements au dessus du prix de
vente de l'électricité j'imagine qu'il y
a eu des alertes sur l'entrée en vigueur
de la reine est-ce qu'il y a eu des
alertes est-ce qu'il y a eu des allèles
tout près des autres gouvernements après
coup vous avez dit vous étiez attaché à
ne pas troubler les relations avec les
gouvernements mais en gros est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire un peu ce qu'on
répondit les gouvernements successifs
sur ce sujet de la reine et enfin ma
dernière question
avec tout ce que vous présentez depuis
le début sur les investissements assez
quand même nécessaire dans le nucléaire
à la fois pour créer le parc pour le
maintenir et puis pour garder la filière
industrielle en vie sur le fait que le
marché ne peut pas créer de système en
surcapacité puisque c'est pas son
intérêt économique que la reine est une
pilule empoisonnée pour toutes ces
raisons pensez-vous que que le système
de production d'électricité ne
devrait-il pas être renationalisé qu'on
ne devrait pas retourner un tarif
réglementé pour tous les secteurs je
vous remercie
merci
vous avez un petit pancarte
la différence entre vous et moi bon
alors sur le
première question c'est les retards
est-ce que
on aurait pu les éviter alors d'abord
petite correction quand je dis qu'il a
sur capacité nucléaire
c'est pas plus clair c'est-à-dire le
nucléaire non mais je veux dire s'il y
avait s'il avait du nucléaire il y
aurait pas eu de surcapacité et c'est
l'ensemble du système qui était en
surcapacité et d'ailleurs
comme je l'ai dit alors c'est vrai
j'avais pas pensé à le dire plus tôt
mais le la surcapacité et le fait gênant
c'était surtout quand on était obligé
d'arrêter les centrales nucléaires parce
que alors là c'est vraiment du
gaspillage quand on arrêtait une
centrale thermique c'est pas c'est pas
très grave puisque
c'était c'est fait pour ça c'est fait
pour être en pointe et donc c'est un une
optimisation du système là où le la
surcapacité c'est quand elle est obligé
d'arrêter des unités qui vaudrait mieux
ne pas arrêter dans l'intérêt du bilan
économique bon sur les les retards
actuels
[Musique]
ma conviction
je ne le crois pas mais je ne peux pas
l'affirmer je pense comme vous le voyez
que les investissements ont été
fortement relancés
quand j'étais aux commandes là comme
vous voulez et je tiens à témoigner que
mes successeurs ont continué je suis pas
du tout en train de pas du tout ils ont
continué je sais pas la courbe si vous
leur demandez mais ils ont continué les
investissements donc de ce point de vue
il n'y a pas eu de de prise de risque
qui aurait été de ne pas entretenir
correctement le parc
non ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
le paradoxe
quand ce EDF qui a décidé ça en 74 du
temps de boiteux a décidé de fabriquer
toutes les centrales nucléaires sur le
même modèle
je m'en souviens
j'étais
la cabine mystérieuse d'avoir entendu
parler c'était une option qui était une
prise de risque je me souviens que ce
sujet avait été évoqué parce que
quelqu'un disait si vous faites toutes
les centrales sur le même modèle c'est
très bien parce qu'il y a des économies
d'échelle vous allez aller plus vite ça
a été une réussite totale mais il y a un
risque
cerise s'appelle le risque systémique
c'est-à-dire si vous trouvez une petite
pépin quelque part il y a une chance non
nulle qu'il est soit partout
et ça c'était honnêtement l'obsession de
tout le monde depuis le début depuis
1974 jusque là un ça s'était pas produit
deux ça c'est pas produit ailleurs je
sais pas produit aux États-Unis où il y
a les mêmes bon
je pense que vous aurez l'occasion d'en
parler avec les personnes qui sont aux
commandes aujourd'hui alors il se trouve
que
bon ce pépin on savait que ça pouvait se
produire c'est clair
honnêtement il n'est pas lié au montant
des investissements à mon avis mais vous
allez faire l'enquête pour ça mais je ne
le pense pas voilà je vous donne mon
opinion mais il faut que vous fassiez
vous pouvez même le jugement mais je le
pense pas je pense que c'est vraiment
quelque chose
qui était un risque qui est modeste
aujourd'hui puisque ça ne concerne que
vous savez un circuit de secours c'est
modeste mais on savait que ça pouvait
arriver alors par contre moi alors la
banque fibre donne mon sentiment mais
vous aurez à le vérifié peut-être que si
on avait une filière plus forte
avec plus d'entreprises plus
d'ingénieurs on aurait été plus vite à
le traiter voilà
mais je pense pas qu'on leur a évité
voilà
et puis bien sûr que si on avait des
surcapacités le problème se verrait pas
pour vous sachiez ce qu'on a fermé entre
flamant ville et les et Le Havre panier
tout ça pas poli
et bien on a fermé à peu près ce qui
nous manque aujourd'hui il faut que vous
le sachiez c'est l'heure de grandeur
c'est pas les 50 000 terrain hauteurs
qu'on exportait ça évidemment on
l'aurait pas mais ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez une
journée qui nous manque ce qui nous
manque c'est leur demandeur de ce qu'on
a fermé
et ça bon
je pense pas que ça soit
des décisions d'investissement rationnel
alors qu'est-ce que vous m'avez demandé
le
tarifs de la reine oui ah oui ah pardon
oui alors une correction madame le ce
que je vous ai donné là le graphique
qu'on ne se méprenne pas
les courbes que vous avez pleines qui
montrent le montant des investissements
l'unité de mesure sont des milliards et
c'est l'échelle de gauche
bon mais les tarifs c'était pour cent et
c'est l'échelle de droite donc ce n'est
pas c'est pas des montants en valeur
absolue qui peuvent se comparer mais
néanmoins je l'ai pas donné mais je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure ce qui est vrai c'est
que
j'ai eu à vivre dans la dernière année
j'ai un graphique aussi je peux vous le
donner mais le fait ça s'est purement
comptable le cash flow généré par
l'activité en France
devenait inférieur non pas à nous c'est
pas que l'entreprise perdait de l'argent
pas du tout elle était bénéficiaire mais
elle ne générez pas assez de cash pour
faire les investissements donc la
variable d'ajustement c'est de
s'endetter la différence mais un
endettement qui n'a aucune chance d'être
rentable puisque ça va être permanent
troisième question
sur le alors ça on appelle ça le thème
que vous évoquez c'est un sujet de débat
d'échange
on appelle ça on appelait ça maintenant
le Market design c'est quel est le
système qui permet de fixer le prix de
l'électricité
de manière optimale alors c'est il y a
des tas des échanges actuellement
si vous voulez il y a deux modèles qui
s'opposent mais je pense qu'il faut
trouver un compromis entre les deux vous
avez le modèle libéral comme il marchait
c'est ce qui existe pour le pétrole le
pétrole tout le monde trouve normal que
par moment le prix du pétrole explose
puis par moment il tombe en bas et les
entreprises m'ont des moments elles
perdent de l'argent mais le plus souvent
je regarde beaucoup voilà mais avec ça
on a des sociétés qui ont les races
solides et qui arrivent à investir il y
a pas il y a pas de pénurie
d'investissement dans le pétrole par
moment vous savez quand le pétrole et
longtemps bas on se dit ils arrêtent les
investissements mais bon elles ont les
insolites en gros ça va pour
l'électricité c'est plus délicat parce
que
surtout pour le nucléaire moins pour les
autres mais pour le nucléaire les
investissements sont à durer très longue
un investissement dans le nucléaire ne
peut pas être rentable avant 30 ans 20
ans donc en effet il faut une garantie
de prix alors soit la garantie de prix
bah c'est la régulation c'est l'État qui
fixe les tarifs et donc là ça a très
bien marché sauf que je vous ai dit
c'est mon témoignage j'ai pas tout à
fait réussi à convaincre l'état quand je
suis à la fin de mon mandat d'augmenter
les tarifs et ça a énervé voilà
mais c'est le système de régulation
alors entre les deux alors entre les
deux il y a un système qui fonctionne
pas mal
en Angleterre et que on est en train
d'utiliser pour le renouvelable c'est à
dire l'État garantit le prix
un certain niveau qui est négocié
contractuellement quand on construit
l'investissement il garantit le prix si
le prix est au-dessus
l'entreprise exploitant verse une
contribution à l'état et si le prix est
en dessous l'État verse une contribution
d'entreprise c'est le modèle qui est
retenu qui a été retenu pour le
renouvelable et il faut évidemment
l'appliquer pour le nucléaire mais c'est
refusé par Bruxelles parce que Bruxelles
dit on n'est pas un monopole
alors il y a d'autres formules et mais
certainement il y a un consensus
aujourd'hui pour dire que le système
actuel ne marche pas
il y a des gens comme vous que je peux
comprendre d'ailleurs qui est de dire
revenons au système des fixes et des
prix fixés par l'État le problème c'est
que l'État n'est pas toujours
raisonnable ou la Commission de
régulation donc
voilà mais il y a des mécanismes
hybrides il y a des gens qui
réfléchissent là dessus
merci Madame Leernes
oui merci
moi j'ai plusieurs questions donc Julie
derrière nous et je suis membre du
groupe des écologistes de la nuit Pesse
ça vous savez d'où on parle
effectivement vous avez bien raison de
d'interroger je ne sais pas pourquoi
nous n'avons pas de chevalet je suis par
ailleurs vice-présidente de cette
commission d'enquête
je voulais vous interroger premièrement
sur ce que vous avez dit au démarrage et
on le revoit d'ailleurs dans les
graphiques sur les énergies
renouvelables vous avez cité en début de
cette audition que vous aviez très vite
compris que les qualités nécessaires
pour développer les énergies
renouvelables vous les aviez pas en
interne et c'est pour ça que vous les
avez externalisé et en parallèle si on
prend vos propos sur
l'inquiétude sur la perte de compétences
d'EDF dans le nucléaire et donc la
nécessité de relancer aussi des
centrales nucléaires avec le cycle ma
question première et pourquoi quelque
part eDF n'a pas converti des
compétences qu'ils avaient avec des
hommes et des femmes et vous le dites et
vous n'êtes pas le seul ici qu'on a
auditionné dit où on avait besoin
quelque part pour maintenir les
compétences et le savoir-faire il y a
des savoir-faire qui peuvent se
transférer d'une industrie à une autre
et donc pourquoi avoir choisi résolument
la voix du nucléaire et pas réellement
en interne avoir développé les énergies
renouvelables
d'autant plus que vous aviez avant que
l'Europe ne décide de séparer EDF et
enedis aussi la compétence sur les
réseaux et là aussi il y avait avec
l'avènement des énergies renouvelables
au-delà du compteur Linky j'ai envie de
dire des investissements à faire dans ce
sens là je voulais vous interroger parce
que j'ai pas complètement compris au
tout début de votre propos vous avez dit
que la baisse de dynamique
sur l'investissement dans le nucléaire
datait de 2004 et je ne sais pas à quoi
vous le reliez exactement en 2004
puisque vous citez ensuite des
événements politiques
ultérieurs et pas 2004 et d'autant plus
que la décision sur en ville a été prise
juste après
en fait je voulais vous interroger donc
sur Flamanville également
monsieur le Président de la Commission
et le rapporteur sont revenus aussi
dessus mais il me semble que quand la
Cour des comptes pointe qu'il y a pas de
vrais équipe projet jusqu'en 2015 est-ce
que pour vous c'est un des éléments en
tout cas ça interpelle donc est-ce que
pour vous c'est un des éléments
fondamentaux aussi pour dire toutes les
défaillances qu'il y a sur Flamanville
c'est bien que les Chinois apprennent
des pépins de nos centrales nucléaires
mais voilà ça interroge quand même
puisqu'on est aussi sur la souveraineté
et énergétique de la France je voulais
vous interroger aussi puisque vous avez
vous avez fait référence sur
la relance de construction de paires
mais également le partenariat avec
l'Angleterre le père de Flamanville lui
aussi le père de Finlande excusez-moi
à lui aussi 12 années de retard et puis
le père chinois dont vous avez fait
référence aussi l'un est à l'arrêt
depuis juillet 2021 pour des problèmes
techniques également et donc voilà c'est
vous dites c'est flamant ville qui pose
problème mais en réalité on voit que sur
ce modèle là sur les quatre qui ont été
relancés il y a des problèmes divers et
variés une question sur la crise
énergétique vous avez fait référence
aussi au tout début de votre propos en
fait la situation est quand même assez
analogue sur la disponibilité du parc
nucléaire de l'année 2009 où vous étiez
encore là c'est à dire quand vous
dirigez EDF il y avait 19 centrales sur
59 qui était à l'arrêt et RTE prononçait
un avertissement sur les mois à venir
pour l'hiver à venir et là il y avait
pas de covid il y avait pas de guerre en
Ukraine et donc comment se fait-il que
plus de 10 ans après nous soyons dans
une situation qui est assez analogue
avec une baisse de la disponibilité du
parc nucléaire
vous avez d'ailleurs été épinglé dans le
rapport de l'inspecteur général Pierre
virotte qui était en charge de contrôler
cela
je voulais pour pas être trop trop
longue et usurper mon temps de parole
juste simplement sur le prolongement des
centrales en 2008 vous parliez de
prolonger la durée de vie du parc
nucléaire jusqu'à 60 ans et aujourd'hui
EDF n'a toujours pas fourni d'éléments
attestant que cela sera réellement
possible et donc sur quoi s'appuyer vos
déclarations de l'époque et comment
expliquer vous que presque 15 ans plus
tard EDF ne puisse pas se prolon
prononcés sur la possibilité de
prolonger le parc jusqu'à 60 ans et
est-ce que c'est relatif à des problèmes
de sûreté ou de sécurité et puis ma
dernière question nous avons été
interrogé hier
des membres du CEA et notamment le
président de la semaine qui nous a dit
que puisque nous avons reçu en tout cas
j'ai reçu en tant que député de nombreux
documents de la semaine et donc
il nous a expliqué que cette société
savante était financée par un certain
nombre de membres qui avaient un budget
de 2 millions d'euros et que tous les
partenaires et les industriels de la
filière nucléaire dont EDF financé cette
filière je voulais savoir ce qu'il en
était en toute transparence et puis à
quelle fin vous financez la semaine je
vous remercie
bon c'est beaucoup de questions si j'en
oublie vous me relancez
la baisse d'investissement c'est là donc
oui compétences donc ça commence avec
les compétences compétences de DF le
malheureusement
[Musique]
dans le enfin pas malheureusement mais
de fait dans le renouvelable EDF n'est
pas n'est pas fabricant de d'équipement
la particularité du nucléaire qui est
une spécificité et d'ailleurs contestée
justement par Eva c'est que EDF était en
même temps
un générique et exploitant
on participait à la construction des
centrales avec Areva donc participa
conscience central dans le renouvelable
pas du tout dans le renouvelable on
achète les équipements et on les
exploite on n'est pas du tout dans la
filière on n'y est pas et
bon c'est les investissements colossaux
on n'y est pas du tout et
malheureusement
l'Europe a pris du retard dans cette
dans cette métier d'équipement il y a eu
des tentatives en Allemagne notamment
dans le soleil et je crois que c'est en
Norvège ou en Suède dans le l'éolien
Bestas mais on a été doublé par les
Chinois aujourd'hui les équipements dans
le renouvelable sont largement chinois
je crois qu'ils ont 50% du marché
vérifié mais c'est l'ordre de grandeur
lors de grandeur ce qui est pas du tout
cas dans le nucléaire
ma question est justement là dessus
c'est à dire que c'est quand même un
choix à un moment donné stratégique def
j'entends le dumping chinois sur le
photovoltaïque tout ça qu'on a perdu la
compétence en Europe mais du coup
pourquoi
parce qu'il y a des compétences qui
étaient transférables
y compris pour fabriquer du matériel
renouvelable
c'est pas du tout enfin vraiment c'est
une compétence que EDF n'estime pas
avoir ce que nous faisons dans le dans
le nucléaire c'est l'ingénierie on
fabrique pas les équipements mais c'est
un ingénierie
on pourrait peut-être participer dans
l'ingénierie à côté de quelqu'un mais
l'industrie européenne n'est pas
développée du tout c'est malheureusement
et non eDF n'a jamais été concerné par
ça
la même jamais envisagé par contre comme
exploitant c'est important parce que
le mix énergétique
et c'était déjà l'analyse qu'on faisait
le dans des proportions qui doivent
rester
sans doute
limité enfin avec des avec des limites
l'éolien apporte quelque chose il
apporte un optimum économique il y a pas
de doute quand il y a les conditions le
permettent et quand le réseau le permet
c'est un optimum économique et donc il
était important en tant que producteur
que que EDF y participe et pour
développer aujourd'hui de de
du solaire et de l'éolien le le
leur jeu c'est-à-dire un enjeu qui est
plutôt
environnementale c'est d'arriver à
trouver et de
de trouver les emplacements et
trouver un optimum qui fasse que les
perturbations sur l'environnement ne
remettent pas en cause le projet et ça
c'est un peu
il y a une vraie compétence là-dedans la
filiale qu'on avait maintenant qui
s'appelle EDF énergie nouvelle je crois
elle était rebaptisée après elle réussit
à ses biens dans ce domaine mais c'est
un métier de plutôt dans d'étude
d'environnement mais pas du tout de
d'ingénierie alors deuxième sujet
sur la baisse des investissements en
2004 alors
là le mon graphique c'est en effet les
investissements ont baissés en 2004 non
c'est pas du tout imposé par l'État ça
c'est un choix qui avait été fait par
l'entreprise
qui était que en continuant à faire 5
centrales par an
le temps que le le
frein
agisse la machine fabriquée encore des
centrales et on l'étale on était amené
en 2000 dans les années 90 avoir trop de
centrales voilà mais c'était c'est EDF
qui honnêtement c'est EDF qu'il a pris
j'étais pas là mais c'est EDF qui a pris
conscience et qui a arrêté d'investir
donc c'est pas une décision à poser du
tout par le le gouvernement
par contre mon analyse c'était que en
faisant ça on en a oublié de regarder ce
qui était les investissements de
maintenance
mais aussi il y a une raison de
calendrier c'était que ça faisait 10 ans
ou 15 ans que les centrales étaient
construites et donc il était normal de
se mettre à refaire de la maintenance et
donc on avait une Centrale qui a moins
de 10 ans il y a les frais de
maintenance en bas par contre ce qui
m'avait frappé moi c'était que d'autres
outils comme l'hydraulique avait pas
fait d'objet d'investissement depuis
longtemps et ça ça a duré mais mes
successions on continue
alors Flamanville
pardon
j'ai pas compris
l'absence d'équipe projet jusqu'en 2015
oui pardon oui oui absolument c'est
l'organisation vous avez raison non
c'est une bonne question alors
que de remarques
le
[Musique]
EDF n'avait pas construit de centrale
depuis presque 20 ans
donc il y avait certainement une une
perte de enfin
un affaiblissement de de la compétence
de d'organisation d'ingénierie
deuxièmement
une sous-estimation
évidente de du fait
moi je vais arrêter
mais comment on fait pour arrêter je
sais pas
comment c'est
oui on a sous-estimé le parce que
vous allez bientôt être familier mais je
vous ai dit quand EDF a commencé à
construire centrales il a construit les
mêmes exactement que celle de des
États-Unis Westinghouse et après EDF est
frambatome ensemble les deux équipes
comme je disais qui travaillent ensemble
ont voulu et on fait
adapter le modèle et on a augmenté la
puissance les premières centrales je
sais pas si vous le savez les premières
sont toutes de 900 mégawatts toutes les
Winston westingers sont 200 MW et après
on a augmenté la puissance on est passé
à 1200 et à 1500 pour le père
en faisant ça on a un petit peu modifié
le design mais pas trop
et EDF il a bien fait on a tenu le
rythme et donc je pense que les équipes
se sont dit ben là c'est pareil on l'a
déjà fait on est passé 900 à 1200 1200 à
1300 là on passe à 1500 ça va être
pareil et en fait pas du tout parce que
je sais pas si vous le savez le Pr j'ai
avant de confirmer le père j'avais
beaucoup enfin j'ai pas mal réfléchi à
au sujet le père est issu je pense que
vous le savez ça historiquement d'une
association entre Siemens
Areva EDF et les autorités de régulation
française et allemande et ces gens-là
ont travaillé pendant 10 ans pendant
tout le temps en faisait pas des
centrales nucléaires et c'était l'idée
de faire un
consortium franco-allemand quoi
et avec ça
les problèmes c'est que les les
autorités de sûreté de l'un et de
l'autre et les équipes d'ingénierie
avaient des idées un peu différentes et
pour les faire converger on a rajouté
des choses et donc le père est
aujourd'hui
l'outil complexe beaucoup plus complexe
que ces prédécesseurs et ça ça avait été
sous-estimé
alors je sais pas si vous avez reçu déjà
EDF non pas encore mais vous
expliqueront qu'ils essaient dans les
prochaines générations là de faire un
EPS simplifié je sais pas si ils vont
vous l'a dit pour répondre à l'objection
je viens de dire bon ça c'est la
première chose bon la deuxième c'est
qu'on avait perdu la compétence et si
vous voulez quand EDF fabriqué je sais
pas si vous mesurez ce chantier là quand
on fabrique 5 centrales par an ça veut
dire qu'il y avait un moment donné 30
chantiers nucléaires en France
puisqu'il a durée de vie la durée de
construction c'est au moins 6 ans 30 et
donc les équipes elles passaient d'une à
l'autre elle faisait les 1 à 30 et les
types ils étaient hyper formés hyper
pointus
là on en a fait un et vous avez
quelqu'un à dire on aurait peut-être pu
en faire deux c'est probable que si on
avait fait deux ça aurait coûté moins
cher mais
c'est sûr que on progresse et notre
sentiment et je pense que les dirigeants
les responsables de DF vous le diront on
a appris de Flamanville on pense qu'on
est mieux on a été mieux attachan on
pense qu'on sera mieux en Angleterre
Ikea
Grande-Bretagne oui alors ce que vous
disiez sur tout le monde a eu des
problèmes sur le père oui tout le monde
a eu des problèmes bien sûr mais pas
tous à la même au même niveau quand même
et c'est là où je veux dire que la
courbe d'expérience commence à se voir
Tashan a été beaucoup plus vite que
que Flamanville quand c'est moi qui est
signé Tashan j'ai signé avec les Chinois
quand on a fait ta chaîne l'argument que
je leur ai donné c'est vous allez
bénéficier de du retour d'expérience de
Flamanville et Flamanville tournera
quand vous aurez encore votre chantier
en construction c'est pas ça qui s'est
passé c'est qu'ils ont bien bénéficié du
retour d'expérience et du coup ils ont
démarré avant nous non ça fonctionne bon
il y a des petits pépins de au démarrage
mais comme tout nouveau projet il y a
pas à mon avis vous demanderez il y a
pas de remise en cause du tout ni
à l'eau qui lui auto ils ont un petit
peu pain qui avait rien à voir avec le
nucléaire qui était dans la partie
classique et attacha il y a eu des
petits pépins je crois qu'ils ont été
apparaît à ma connaissance et les
centrales fonctionnent aujourd'hui mais
je je pourrai pas le je l'ai pas vérifié
avant de venir
alors allongement la durée des centrales
sur 60 ans pourquoi pourquoi ils ont
s'est posé la question et pourquoi c'est
pas fait aujourd'hui alors oui oui c'est
un sujet intéressant et important
c'est attention à ce que je dis parce
que c'est très à la sûreté
le disais j'ai l'expérience aéronautique
et
nucléaire les autorités de sûreté
indépendantes existent aux États-Unis
elles existent en France les existent
dans tous les pays et il est très
important qu'elle soit complètement
indépendante et complètement reconnue
comme tel je pense
j'espère que vous le confirmerez c'est
le cas en France l'Autorité de sûreté
est reconnue comme indépendante
et donc l'opinion publique lui fait
confiance
c'est essentiel l'acceptabilité du
nucléaire ne passe que comme ça c'est
même pour l'aéronautique c'est pareil
on accepte de monter dans un avion que
parce qu'on est sentiments que c'est sûr
alors
la philosophie de l'Autorité de sûreté
américaine et l'autorité sur tes
françaises n'est pas la même sur un
point
aux États-Unis c'est comme pour les
Renault TIC on considère qu'une centrale
nucléaire aujourd'hui
pour qu'elle puisse continuer à vivre il
faut qu'elle soit conforme à ce qu'elle
était le jour où elle a été approuvée
vous voyez ce que je veux dire elle
était elle était approuvée le jour de
son démarrage il faut qu'elle soit
pareille aujourd'hui et donc s'il y a
des
usures des trucs il faut corriger les
usures mais on ne lui demande pas
d'améliorer la sécurité en fonction des
innovations qui ont pu être découvertes
entre temps
un avion pareil si vous volez encore
dans un 747 sachez il avait 50 ans il y
a pas une modification sur l'avion
depuis 50 ans
les avions nouveau sont plus sûrs parce
qu'il y a les automatismes mais
alors la philosophie des américains et
qui est vrai pour le erotique c'est de
dire attention dès qu'on innove on prend
un risque
donc on est 9 pas
la France est différente la France
demande à ce qu'on incorpore dans les
centrales existantes un certain nombre
d'éléments d'amélioration de la sûreté
et donc clairement aujourd'hui je ne
connais pas le dossier je demanderai
mais
débats qui doit y avoir entre DF et
l'Autorité de sûreté c'est qu'est-ce
qu'ils émettent comme amélioration par
rapport à ce qui existe aujourd'hui ce
qui n'est pas le cas aux États-Unis aux
États-Unis ils ont prolongé à
l'identique
cette différence entre l'Autorité de
sûreté
américaine et française je pense qu'il
faut peut-être une Fukushima en 2011 qui
a rajouté une couche sur la sûreté
nécessaire pour prolonger la durée de
vie mais est-ce que c'était déjà le cas
en 2008 c'est-à-dire en 2008 vous disait
il faut prolonger jusqu'à 60 ans et
aujourd'hui on a toujours pas de plan
pour le faire c'est ça un peu
ça m'étonne parce que moi je vais il
faut savoir que
j'ai dit que entre EDF et le
gouvernement il peut pas y avoir de de
d'écart d'opinion entre EDF et
l'Autorité de sûreté il ne peut pas y
avoir des cartes d'opinion
et si on n'est pas d'accord surtout on
en parle pas on en discute non je veux
dire publiquement on voit ensemble pour
trouver une solution
c'est ce que je faisais avec mon
interlocuteur qui était à monsieur qui
s'appelle Lacoste qui était une
réputation mondiale qui était on
discutait ensemble et nous étions
arrivés
oralement d'accord pour dire que c'était
possible en 2008
mais il restait à faire le dossier était
pas fait mais c'était possible et je
crois que c'est possible je pense que ça
soit mais la question c'est qu'est-ce
que il va falloir faire comme
investissement complémentaire et ça
c'est une discussion et je pense qu'elle
est pas sur la place publique et c'est
bien qu'elle ne lui soit pas
c'est tout CEA sen je sais pas trop ce
que c'est c'est la société française de
je sais pas
mais voilà bon j'ai pas d'avis sur le
sujet ce que je peux vous dire j'étais
pas au courant mais
je respectable je trouve que c'est bien
qu'il y a des gens qui réfléchissent il
y a pas de doute
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
il y a encore des questions seulement et
même monsieur ganonex on vous remercie
très sincèrement pour ces deux heures
d'audition
pour la précision des informations que
vous et des souvenirs que vous avez
partagé avec nous puisque
il y a une quand on entre dans dans
l'histoire de d'une grande maison comme
EDF il y a forcément des éléments qui ne
sont pas que factuels mais qui sont
aussi de l'ordre de l'anecdote du
souvenir et
les papiers que vous avez été oui que je
les retrouve
c'est les papiers qui peut servir à
faire le point de la situation vis-à-vis
des de nos différents interlocuteurs et
j'étais bluffé les retrouver mais ça m'a
fait plaisir voilà donc merci beaucoup
pour votre disponibilité et
la façon dont vous avez répondu à nos
questions je donne rendez-vous au membre
de notre commission la semaine prochaine
pour un programme chargé puisque nous
auditionnerons successivement je vous
donne tout de suite le menu Michel
Laurent directeur général de l'énergie
du climat Henri Proglio qui a succédé à
Monsieur ganonex à la présidence d'EDF
Monsieur François Brotte au titre des
fonctions qu'il exerçait de président du
directoire de RTU ce Jean-Bernard Lévy
dont le mandat de président d'EDF a
succédé à celui de Proglio et vient de
prendre fin Monsieur Xavier pechadique
actuel président du directoire de RTE
Madame Anne lovergeon ancienne
présidente d'Areva et Monsieur Patrick
landais au commissaire à l'énergie
atomique voilà pour les la semaine
prochaine le menu qui nous attend avant
avant la trêve des confiseurs comme on
l'appelle encore
merci beaucoup monsieur ganenex si vous
voulez non juste
est-ce que vous attendez encore quelque
chose de moi parce que vous avez envoyé
un questionnaire est-ce que les vous
avez les réponses à la question
écoutez on va chier à des questions
complémentaires vous me dites parce que
beaucoup de questions qui sont dans le
je l'avais lu le questionnaire je
m'étais forcé d'y répondre donc si il y
a des questions encore résiduelles vous
m'envoyez un papier mais je n'en vois
pas de contribution écrite
supplémentaires on est d'accord moi
j'avais juste sur les dividendes je vous
avais la poser la question si vous aviez
peut-être un graphique plus détaillé du
montant des dividendes qui ont été versé
à mettre en comparaison justement avec
la trésorerie le cash flow de def j'ai
honnêtement j'ai été sur je l'ai et le
chercher sur Wikipédia donc
vous pouvez la voir
mais c'est important c'est vous avez
raison c'est colossal le total des
dividendes versées pendant la période
depuis que l'entreprise a été le capital
était ouvert et de 45 milliards
de savoir que les outils d'aide à la
prise de décision sont
tourne autour de lui
écouteur heureusement que ça y est
heureusement que le montant des
dividendes est connu transparent et
allez merci beaucoup monsieur ganonix la
séance élevé